all right everybody i am dave rubin of
the reuben report and we're doing
something special today
we've got a three hour stream for you
that will be
streaming right here on the reuben
report youtube channel
as well as the freedom fest youtube
channel and at freedomfrest.com
and i am joined by mark scouse and he is
the
founder of freedomfest and we're doing
an emergency meeting here we were
supposed to do
a live event in august i was going to be
there in las vegas we were going to talk
about
all things freedom and libertarian and
classical liberal and all that stuff
that i'm always talking about
on the show right here and then
obviously because of kobit we were
unable to do the live events so we are
doing a massive live stream today
we are bringing in i don't know how many
people but it's
probably probably a couple dozen people
that we're gonna have all sorts
of conversations with on a wide range of
topics and
of course as you may have seen last
night there was a
presidential debate so i think we'll get
to that as well uh
but let me first bring in mark so you
can find out a little bit
about uh freedom fest and what he's been
up to and sort of what we're going to do
today
mark good morning good morning dave it's
very uh it's a real pleasure to be on
the show with you
and i know you are going to be one of
our keynote speakers at freedom fest
in in july in las vegas and yes the
lockdown
shut us down and uh
you know it's nice to see you smiling me
smiling i think
biden was the only one smiling uh last
night that
you know it seemed like trump was really
in a in a uh
kind of a rough mood there but uh
we'll talk we are going to talk about
that but you know that debate
last night that brawl if you will kind
of reflects
uh why we're having this emergency
meeting this is unprecedented not only
in terms of
what uh what happened the the
anger the the the fight over what's
happening in this country
is the reason why this is our second
emergency meeting
it is via zoom and it is really
important that we recognize
that lots of things are unprecedented
not just the pandemic
but the runaway uh easy money aggressive
monetary policy where the money supply
is growing at 25 percent
we have government spending that is
totally out of control nobody cares
about the deficits anymore they're
trillions of dollars
uh we're talking about never-ending wars
there's lots of problems that we face
and it's affecting
our way of life our culture
and our portfolio so there's a lot of
reasons for us to have this emergency
meeting it's not to say we're not going
to meet in person in fact
next july we are going to be meeting
again
at freedom fest and we were hoping dave
that you will join us
it's going to be in person we're
absolutely determined to meet
in person because that's what freedom
fest is all about
that's what freedom is all about so yes
this emergency meeting we have totally
new speakers that we haven't had before
including you as a host and uh
i did want to you know it would be nice
if you could just spend a minute do you
you've written a really interesting book
to describe
today's uh unusual environment uh
you know don't burn this book uh so
maybe you can you have a copy of the
book you can show us and tell us a
little bit about there
there's a copy right over there over my
what is that that's my right shoulder
um yeah i'll tell you a little bit about
the book but i should also tell you that
i am looking forward to
next year's event in vegas because
believe it or not i've only been to
vegas once and i stayed at circus circus
so i don't know that i've done vegas
correctly okay so
i am overdue i am overdue to get back to
vegas
uh well very quickly uh i also want to
talk about what exactly freedom fest is
and and why you started it but but
quickly on my book and sort of why we're
doing this on my channel
when when we realized that the event
wasn't going to happen this
august uh i immediately said to my guys
i was like all right well let's talk to
the freedom fest people
and see if there's a way we can host a
virtual event obviously i'm i'm more
than happy
to host it and we're going to be
bringing in a whole bunch of of
experts and thinkers and philosophers
and authors over the next three hours
but as for my book i mean don't burn
this book really
it's a defense of classical liberalism
and
you know that is the the set of ideas
based on
individual rights and logic and reason
and limited government and
laissez-faire economics that i believe
are the right set of ideas to free the
most amount of people and
and allow human beings to to flourish in
the best way possible
that's pretty in line with a lot of the
stuff that uh
freedom fest and you guys talk about and
that many of the guests we're going to
bring on
talk about uh so i was really glad that
you know the book did so well
because you know we live in a time where
if you watch the debates
last night it's not like you're hearing
a lot about the right ideas you hear
politicians
try to get each other and then you hear
moderators
ask loaded questions and everyone
everyone feels confused i i don't think
there was anyone
that watched that debate last night that
walked away going oh i feel
better about the country or i feel
better about our future
or or i have a better understanding of
the issues so don't burn this book
really was
uh for me it was sort of classical
liberalism
libertarianism and and hopefully enough
people
will have read it that it will it will
affect
you know what happens in november um but
before we before we move on to the next
segment i just
i just want to let my audience find out
a little bit more about you and why you
started freedom fest so can you
can you help me out there i sure can
dave thank you very much
and uh you brought up a lot of things in
your book and about this
debate last night that gives you an idea
of what freedom fest is all about so
we're an intellectual feast
in the entertainment capital of the
world which is very unusual
uh uh uh oscar goodman the mayor of las
vegas said
freedom fest is the most unique
conference in
las vegas so we discuss philosophy
history science and technology
geopolitics investments
healthy living we have the anthem film
festival
that's put on every year it's just a
we have several thousand people who
gather who
want a civil discussion about issues and
we
focus on issues we focus on history and
philosophy
rather than who is right we want to
focus on what is right
and all of our debates and we're famous
for our debates
we had a debate last year for example
between john mackey the ceo of whole
foods markets
and kevin o'leary of shark tank and was
on the whole issue
of what is the purpose of business is it
to make a lot of money or is it to
fulfill a higher purpose and it was a
rock and roll debate but it was
extremely civil nobody talked over each
other
uh we we had uh we respected
each other's views and uh so
people walk away from freedom fest and
say this is the most unique conference
that i've ever been to because we really
do
talk about ideas we do try to
persuade each other and not engage in
the name calling we we
try to avoid as much as possible oh you
are the radical left you are the radical
right
uh you're liberal you're conservative uh
let's talk about specific issues let's
talk about
individuals who hold those positions
rather than these labels that demonize
people and divide people
freedom fest people gather together and
they're from different political
persuasions
we have investors who come who are not
necessarily
uh the classical liberals uh but we get
to discuss these issues so that's just a
little bit of a summary
steve forbes and john mackie are
co-ambassadors
we've had very uh we always have uh very
uh unique individuals
who come and speak we've had william
shatner we've had george foreman we've
had george will
kevin o'leary uh now this last year we
were supposed to have jordan peterson
uh maybe even give us a little update on
jordan peterson because he was not able
to come
you're unfortunately yeah no i
as as my audience knows i i spent a year
and a half touring with jordan we did
about 120 stops in
in roughly 20 countries it when i look
back on that year and a half of my life
it
it almost seems like a dream i mean we
we talked to
literally hundreds of thousands of
people and and every single show was
sold out and it was absolutely
incredible
uh as as most people know jordan is
dealing with some health stuff right now
i can't i can't unfortunately say more
than is sort of publicly known
uh suffice to say his next book will be
coming out uh early next year
and i think we'll we'll hear from him
publicly around then
he's getting better but yeah i can't i
can't say much more but
but what i can tell you is that the
ideas that you just discussed there
and and talking about the individual and
freedom and and
and purpose which sounds like it was
part of that debate that you guys hosted
those were the ideas that jordan was
putting forth and what i love is when
you can you can talk about sort of
economic principles but
they're not disconnected from human
principles of of finding purpose and
reason
and things like that so uh man i wish we
were i wish we were doing this in perp
in person but you know these wires of
the internet will have to work for today
yes indeed well i look forward to it
very much and yes
being in person does make a difference
we can have our zoom meeting
and we can express some views but
there's nothing like
the the personal touch and i think the
debate last night was a perfect example
that were they were not allowed to even
shake hands
that's not going to happen at freedom
fest we're going to shake hands we may
even do a brasso who knows
i said to i said to my agent when we
signed the deal with you guys
it was obviously during covid and i said
i'm looking forward
to getting out there and signing books
and shaking hands with people i don't
remember the last time i shook someone's
hand
all right uh we gotta we got a couple
hours for you guys we got some really
great speakers lined up some of the
people i've talked to before and had on
my show
there's gonna be a whole bunch of people
that will be introducing you to for the
first time and for those of you that are
familiar with freedomfest i think
there's gonna be a lot of
uh familiar names but first we're going
to throw to a commercial
from the atlas society let's take a look
but even if in some fantasy world or
parallel
universe socialism did produce i would
still
oppose it and you should still oppose it
because it is evil and the reason it is
evil is because
it infringes upon the rights of the
individual but of course if we're
interested in a politics of liberty
it's important for every individual to
have the confidence and the confidence
in his or her
increasingly her own judgment so they
can understand the way the world
actually is in order to live
successfully in it
iran is making a comeback and the atlas
society
is making it happen
all right we're back we are gonna start
off today with a half
hour segment talking about the pandemic
this is titled the pandemic pandemonium
and uh matt i'm gonna let you take it
away no sorry mark i'm gonna let you
take it away
i was throwing it to our guest before i
threw it to my co-host well we have
three
three guests with us and we're very
and these are all experts who have had
lots of experience with
the pandemic or the covet 19 or the
chinese flu that that
that president trump used the term uh uh
at
last night's debate i want to start well
let me first quickly
introduce each one of our panelists we
have lord matt ridley
from the uk who's a member of the house
of lords
and so he's coming to us all the way
across the
the pond and uh an author
and a scientist uh and has written
extensively
on the uh uh the the
virus the coronavirus that we've faced
and its impact
uh then we have johan uh norberg
from sweden who is a senior fellow
at the cato institute and an author as
well and his free to choose videos
we absolutely love uh
that it's just great what is it like a
one minute uh
a couple of minutes uh dispelling a lot
of the
myths that are out there love that i
think everybody would really enjoy that
and then dr joel uh mercola
who is one of the world's experts uh
medical and md and expert on
uh the covet 19 and so forth so we
we have a great group here and so i'll
ask
questions uh and and dave will ask
questions and let's have a
a really good session so let me start
with mark mark before we uh
mark before we get to the first question
i just have to point out that let it
never be said that freedom fest guests
are not well read because there are
roughly one billion books
in that in that image right there but
these guys
it's very very true they are authors and
don't forget us
we write books too
uh so matt i let me let me
ask you this question didn't you start
off as a
super alarmist uh warning that millions
of people were going to dive
uh based on the models that were created
what have you learned since then uh is
is it as bad
as we expected uh what have we learned
and have you
have you gone from being an alarmist to
a skeptic
or how do you put yourselves in this
spectrum dealing with the uh
the lockdown and all that sort of thing
give us your perspective
historically how you have changed your
views over time
yeah well mark i i i'm a bit all over
the place like a lot of us on this we're
changing our minds as we go along but
10 years ago i wrote a book called the
rational optimist which i said the
world's getting better not worse
and i did say in that one of the things
that might go wrong in this century
is a pandemic and i at one point said it
might come from
bats if we do because of sars and mers
and these other ones
but i got pretty reassured about our
ability to get ahead of a virus
because of uh genomic skills
because the uh bird flu swine flu sars
failed to mount a
major challenge to the human race um and
so uh i entered this
this year not expecting
a serious problem from the wuhan
stories that were coming out i didn't
think it was going to spread to the west
once it did though
and i realized it had this very strange
combination
of being asymptomatic and
very mild for a lot of people but very
dangerous for a few i realized that this
was actually a very dangerous
combination
and it might be very hard to control it
and i think we've been
we've seen that that is the case we
don't seem to be able to suppress it
with
non-pharmaceutical interventions you
know with lockdowns and things very
effectively
we make a hash of that but we can't get
a vaccine ready we've entered this
year without enough innovation in
vaccine development and things like that
so it has come along in a peculiarly
well-designed way to exploit the
vulnerabilities that we have at the
moment
but as the time has gone on i have
become convinced that a lot of what we
did in the early months
was was wrong we effectively
directed the virus into hospitals and
care homes where it did the most damage
and we didn't allow herd immunity to
build up in the general population
and i think we're going to hear from
johann how sweden did something that was
much more sustainable
and i think we all should be learning a
lot from what the swedes have done
well maybe that's a good uh segway into
johann
uh let's get johan norberg's views uh
johan you're in stockholm right now and
can you tell us uh
there's been a lot of criticism of the
swedish model that it
it resulted in a high level of deaths
compared to norway and denmark and
finland and so forth
uh but but now it seems like the swedish
model is getting
uh a lot of positive uh response that
maybe that was the right way to go
can you give us your perspective on the
swedish model you're an outlier
why how did you come up with this uh
it sounds like uh uh uh
is it turgnell the uh
the the primary figure involved here
does he
deserve the nobel prize in chemistry
well we'll see i guess is the safest
answer
yes sweden is an outlier for the
peculiar
reason that sweden stuck to
the policy that most public health
authorities
actually agreed upon before we had the
pandemic when they were talking about
how should we deal with the pandemic but
then after
china started with a very radical
and authoritarian shutdown seemed like
there was not her immunity but a herd
mentality and every country just
followed
in their footsteps even liberal
democracies in the west
sweden stuck to its guns or well the
lack of
of guns because there weren't many
restrictions
a few government restrictions we stopped
public events with more than 50 people
stopped visits to
nursing homes but apart from that it was
mostly a recommendation
of social distancing trying to trust
swedish citizens to uphold social
distancing
don't go to work if you can avoid it
don't use public transportation if you
can
avoid it don't meet especially not elder
relatives and so on
which meant that there was lots of
social distancing
in sweden even though it left some room
for
individual needs and local knowledge
which i think
makes this more sustainable than a
radical
lockdown lots of people said that sweden
was engaging in a crazy experiment
but in fact in to our suites it looked
like the rest of the world was engaging
in a crazy experiment because the world
has never shut down
like it did uh during this pandemic and
well the result in sweden so far i guess
we'll we have it from new york times
today
in with a big headline vilified early
over lax virus strategy
sweden seems to have scourge controlled
because the early models
said that sweden would by now have some
100
000 deaths from the coronavirus
they only had it wrong by around 94
000 people the model said that 30 to 40
people would
fight over every hospital bed but
in fact we maintained a an excess
capacity in intensive care units by
around 20 all this time we built a
big new field hospital in stockholm with
room for
hundreds of kovid 19 patients that was
never
taken into use because the normal
healthcare system could deal
with the cases and it is now being
dismantled so it seems like at least the
um
the horror version of of what would
happen in sweden
that never took place johann uh
very quickly and dave you can jump in on
this too
here in the united states everything is
all about the mass now you
have to wear the mask the masks are very
protective and
we we want to get uh dr mccola's views
on the mask
as well because that seems to be the
most uh public
uh perspective that if you're wearing a
mask you're protecting yourself
my understanding is no hardly anybody
wears a mask in sweden uh so
do you guys not understand the science
what is your problem
well no there are no legal mandates and
in fact from the public health authority
they say that the
science is not clear when it comes to
masks because if you
use them in the wrong way it might even
make things worse
and it's also something that
might tempt you to be too close to
people and avoid social distancing if
you wear
mosques so it is not happening in sweden
we have rarely used it historically so
it's not really the
swedish culture and it's not at least
the public health authority's take on
science here so i i think that
brings us unless dave you want to make a
comment
mark why don't we why don't we get uh dr
mercola in here and then and then i'll
share some thoughts after that yeah but
i think that would be great so
dr mccola please come in because i know
you've always
you've been a skeptic from day one on
this
uh pandemic uh you're an outlier in some
respects
uh i think the majority of scientists do
think the pandemic is very serious as
as matt ridley was saying uh uh
you need to require the mass you've got
to have a vaccine and so forth so give
us your perspective have you what have
you
learned over the last six months
about this disease and is there a cure
absolutely well you know my partake is
life is a learning journey and
i have great respect for what sweden did
and even though they initially started
the pandemic with a an increase
in death rates most experts now from my
understanding attribute this to their
failure to address the issue in the
elderly population and if
they had done that they would have been
spectacular
but but to this day the results are
confirmed
that they resisted deploying the
strategies recommended by
virtually the entire world population of
my kudos to them
in the united states even prior to the
the uh this year
there has been a progressive suppression
in censorship of information that
addresses the truth
this is done primarily through google
which controls 92 percent of the
searches in the world
and all the social media platforms
facebook and twitter
instagram they are they are suppressing
any
information that directly contradicts
the narrative of the world health
organization and many on this uh video
understand that that
organization is largely funded the
largest funder
outside of the united states which trump
wisely refused to
fund is now bill gates so anything that
conflicts
with what they say is seriously
suppressed and censored
and largely as a result of many
certainly that are largely urban areas
that are democratically controlled and
implemented these strategies are
absolute miserable failures so
fortunately we have some republican
governors i live in the state of florida
governor desantis just
earlier this week deployed a strategy
uh very similar to sweden he stopped
all the restrictions no more social
distancing no more isolation
so uh mask and all the restaurants are
open so
kudos to him and i think we're going to
expand we have not had an increase in
cases
and there's this conflation of you know
once the deaths started going down then
because they're using fear to control
the population and so instead of using
deaths they
switched it over to cases making people
believe that cases is a symptomatic
uh infection when it came when the true
reality is is not
many of these tests are false positive
so
the the what i've learned is that the
the
any information that conflicts with the
narrative
is suppressed and one of the most
important pieces of information is that
we have the capacity to actually control
this this
uh infection in fact the the purpose of
the vaccination program is to stimulate
our own immune system
but very hardly anyone is discussing
the simple strategies that we can do to
activate our own immune system and
one of the ones that i've learned that
is so important is disease and we've
seen studies done
uh specifically on vitamin d there's one
in indonesia and you can bring up the
slide that shows that
where they had 212 patients divided into
four equal groups
of equal approximately equal groups and
the two
most severe cases the ones with severe
and critical
illness 96 of that population with
covert 19
had low vitamin d levels where you go on
the the
other side and those with mild illness
96 of that population had
normal vitamin d levels so that i mean
it doesn't you don't have to be a genius
to understand that there's something to
do with vitamin d
and the elderly and those with a black
skin
are more susceptible to this because
they're unable to literally go outside
and if they can go outside they're not
going to be able to get my
enough vitamin d if you go to the next
slide understanding this i put together
a site that anyone can go to it's called
stopcovetcold.com
that does you don't have to submit an
email or anything and it could
show you how to assess what your risk
factor is for this disease
simple two-minute questionnaire and it
gives you the information
and there's reports that you can
download
that will supply you with
easy-to-understand
information that uh literally because we
don't have enough time to go into
specific details there but it's a
simple strategy and there are many
others like insulin resistance and
metabolic ill health or metabolic and
flexibility where our body
uh uh one of the commons
symptoms of that would be obesity but
what's what's common to obesity and
diabetes and the other
comorbidities like hypertension uh is
that
they are resistant to the hormone
insulin and when you are resistant to
insulin you have a massive
overall suppression of your immune
immune function so just
water functioning together and vitamin d
levels will do enormous levels to
improve your health
and resistance you mentioned you
mentioned obesity and i think that's a
an important issue because we have an
obesity epidemic here in the united
states
but not in europe i mean you go to the
uk you go
to sweden and so on people are thin
right they go to france people are thin
could that be johanna's shaking his head
he's not though away but uk
i don't know maybe i i misinterpreted uh
that issue but uh people have como
morbidity this is an issue as to why
they're suffering
why don't we focus on healthy living
rather than uh
you know we have everyone sequestered at
home the people are gaining weight
they're getting depressed
maybe maybe we're we have the wrong
formula dave you you
you probably need some make make some
comments or ask some questions
yeah well look i'm out here in socal
where everybody looks great and there's
plenty of sunshine so they're getting
vitamin d and everyone looks healthy and
yet we're all
we're all walking around in masks all
day uh but dr mercola actually hit on
two things that i thought was
interesting there
one this is just anecdotal but i i have
a friend whose uh girlfriend is a nurse
here in california
and she said that at the hospital she's
at when you talk about
the case numbers that actually if
someone comes in
with covid they recount that case as
covid every day that they're at the
hospital so if you come in on day one
and they diagnose you with kobit that
counts as one case if you're there for
five days
you're recounted as a new case every day
so that shows you that the numbers
are are a little uh a little screwy and
then what you mentioned sort of about
comment on that all right let me just
say one thing and then we'll throw it to
johan because this is related to the
numbers as well
which is that when we talk about well
trusting the cdc or trusting the who
or the rest of it you know this brings
us to something that's that's very dear
to me and i think
for probably most of the people watching
this which is just also how much power
big tech has over us and you know what
information can be shared and is
considered to be trusted
and what isn't but johan let's throw it
to you
yeah this is an incredibly important
reason why we
should be a little bit cautious about
trying to compare
cases and deaths around the world
because we
don't have a standardized definition for
example in sweden
you if you have or
likely had kovid19 and then you die
within a 30-day period
you are counted as a covid19 death even
though you might have died from
cancer or a heart attack or even run
over by a truck
whereas for ex so you you count those
who die with
kobe 19 rather those who died off
probably 19
whereas in for example a very culturally
and geographically similar country like
norway
they have great statistics but they only
count something as a coveted 19 death
if a doctor looks at this
person and concludes that kovid 19
killed him
and then he reports this to the
authorities as a kovi 19 death
so i think we should wait a long time
and look at excess deaths generally in
countries
before we begin to conclude who
had a success or a fiasco over here
that you had a comment yeah i
particularly just wanted to say one more
thing about sweden which which i think
will interest
johann which is the british media has
gone from
saying out loud and very hysterically
sweden is heading for a catastrophe
there's going to be millions dead in the
streets and so on
to saying no the reason sweden is doing
better than us is because it's a
different country their their system
wouldn't work here
they've got they all live in the in huts
in the forest blah blah blah
you know etc this is ridiculous sweden
is a more urbanized country
than the uk is actually uh and its
total population density is roughly the
same as scotland's which has a bad
epidemic so
the idea you know the way the media has
pivoted
from saying sweden's not going to work
to say sweden has worked but it's a
special case so we can ignore it
it's really really quite striking just
on the point that you were just making
johan
about deaths and and deaths from other
causes
there is good evidence now certainly in
the uk that there is a
pretty bad epidemic of mental illness
coming about as a result of
of this uh um uh problem
and uh it's worse among the young people
than the old
well this is the very group that is not
suffering very badly
from uh the covet virus it's not being
caused by the virus it's being caused by
the lockdown
so it is very probable that in terms of
suicides and other things
that we will have a terrible epidemic
among young people
of of increased problems that will dwarf
anything that the virus does
so we do have to find a way to keep old
people safe from this virus because it
isn't a
safe virus for people older people with
comorbidities
um and at the same time allow
normal life to resume for younger people
because it's a catastrophe what we're
doing to our economy i believe sweden is
still running a surplus
we're not we're running a 300 billion
pound deficit this year
wow wow let's throw it to dr mercola
yeah just to highlight that point uh
less than two weeks ago the cdc in the
united states
admitted that only six percent of the
deaths
from and that's an important preposition
from because that's what the media uses
they said
died two hundred thousand people just
died from no
two hundred thousand people died with
coven 19.
the cdc acknowledges that only six
percent of those
died from it from it so
94 did not die from the virus they
died from release these could these
confounding comorbidities
admitted by the cdc right so that's
about that's about 12
000 people how long is this how long is
this lockdown going to continue
it sounds like from your own perspective
it's a mistake
to engage in this lockdown i understand
it's gotten worse in the uk
uh in terms of the lockdown so how when
are we going to be able to have freedom
fest and have the
the doors opened and some
are we going to be even physically able
to gather together
a couple thousand people in las vegas
next july
or if it's in the uk we could we could
all move to swede we could have freedom
fest in stockholm and we'd be fine right
good idea good idea i mean here in the
northeast of england
we're we're under a renewed lockdown
we're now not allowed to socialize
in each other's homes at all um and
we're not allowed to meet in the pub
with people from other households
and um if we do go to the pub all on our
own we have to be out by ten o'clock
um and all of these laws are going
through
we had a big debate in parliament about
this uh at the beginning of the week
they're going through based on an act
that was passed six months ago
that enabled the government to do
anything it likes basically to lock
people up and
and not have to come back to parliament
to get permission to to
to bring in these new rules and laws and
you know we had a protest vote against
that in the house of lords saying come
on you've got to come back to parliament
and get approval
to do these uh illiberal things that
we're doing to our society
because it isn't working very well it's
very
dangerous from the point of view of the
economics and it's terrifying what it's
doing to
society and to the to the the desire for
people to control each other's lives
what really worries me is that once
government gets hold of these kind of
powers
it doesn't like to give them up too
easily
yeah well i see we all nodded our head
in agreement on that one because that
really gets to the heart
of the reason why freedom fest exists
and why we care about these ideas
that that's totally where i'm worried
about look i'm not a scientist so i can
track the information and listen
to experts like you guys but but that
part the idea that oh i can't make a
decision as an adult
over who is going to enter my home now
i'm in los angeles we've got a pretty
intense lockdown
you are allowed to have people in your
home it sounds like it is
worse at least at the moment in terms of
regulation in the uk
but the fact that we've allowed the
government to say these are
powers that we have over you that's
that's where you get all of my bells as
somebody that cares about
personal freedom you get all those bells
going
and dave i would also add that in the
united states
we have a written constitution
um and in it the bill of rights
clearly says that congress can make no
law to abridge the freedom of peaceful
assembly
freedom of speech freedom of religion
and notice
all of those have been abridged
just carte blanche and our church
leaders
our religious leaders uh our
local leaders our universities
we've all just laid down and said okay
we won't go to church we won't go to
uni university we won't go to
we'll do everything online unfortunately
technology has hurt us
in this respect because let's face it
you wouldn't have closed down the
schools
you wouldn't have closed down the
churches you wouldn't have done any of
this
except now we can do everything online
we can do the zoom
meeting zoom stock has gone through the
roof so
wall street people are delighted with
what's happening and yet
something is missing it's called
privileges
rights freedom liberty
those have all been a bridge and
you know what do you do in countries you
know you're in sweden
do you have do you have rights do you
have privileges
apparently you do yeah we didn't throw
them
overboard the moment uh we were in a
crisis but
unfortunately this fits with a
historical pattern you know h
l main console saying the goal of uh
the demagogue is to keep the populist
alarm and hence clamors
for safety and i actually just published
this book open the story of human
progress
and it's got a very nice endorsement
from matt ridley so it must be good
and there i point to all all the crisis
in history
depressions the pandemics the natural
disasters
what have you it always creates this
kind of societal fight or flight
instinct when we want to be protected by
the the big man
the big government and there are two
major problems with this
the first one is that you never think of
the alternative cost
because yes this might be the way a
shutdown might
at least delay many of the cases and
deaths
but it doesn't take into the calculation
all the things that should have happened
and don't
now people don't go to hospital they
don't go to cancer screening we don't
get
vaccinations around the world in poor
countries we will see
probably an increase in extreme poverty
by somewhere around 100 and to
300 million people another 100 million
people thrown into chronic
undernourishment
because of lack of transportation trade
production the things that we that we
need that's also a dramatic cost
the other thing is that once governments
assume powers like this
it rarely gives them back at least not
in its entirety there's a ratchet
effect they keep much of it and what
worries me
is that historically speaking
this i mean this has been very bad lots
of
cases and deaths and it's terrible
shouldn't be
made light up but historically speaking
it was a relatively mild pandemic
we'll get worse pandemics in the future
we'll see worse
crisis in in other forms in the future
as well
if we're so willing to throw all our
liberties overboard
once we get this what are we willing to
do the next time around
johan uh show us your book again um
the op what's it called open um
and it's a very story of human progress
it kind of surprises me that your book
is so
thick because i would think that uh this
should be one of those thin books in
history
and so your sequel would probably be
called closed
and that'll be a very thick book even
thicker than that one
uh i i'm i really hope that you're
that that book open uh we get back to
that because i'm sure your book was
written before the pandemic began right
actually the second half of the book is
called closed
about all the closures historically
including
in times of pandemics and i even managed
to include some of the
updates one of them
oh uh matt you wanted to make a comment
yeah i just i just wanted to say one of
the
things that i've noticed in this country
and i don't know if it's true elsewhere
is that the people on public salaries
are quite happy
to uh remain locked down because they
can stay at home and
draw their full salaries um and uh they
they don't see what the problem is
um they're quite enjoying it to some
extent and there's a real
double standard here that people in the
private sector are really worried about
their jobs
government is trying to help them but
not for long
and there are job losses occurring on a
massive scale um
whereas civil servants officials in
central government are saying
well no we'll just stay at home and do
the odd zoom meeting and
and you know take the dog for a walk uh
that really worries me is that that
you know the the difference between the
way you're treated
if you're in one sector versus another
you know i feel that
i feel that very intimately here in los
angeles because you know we've got
a progressive big government governor in
gavin newsom who is the former mayor of
san
francisco and we know that it didn't
quite work out there and then we've got
a progressive
mayor here in eric garcetti and then of
course we've also got nancy pelosi
uh you know from california and she's
having ice cream and getting her hair
cut
and you know i can walk to several
restaurants that you know are within a
mile of my house and they're all closed
and they're small businesses
or the best they can do is put two or
four tables outside
and of course that's not sustainable and
you'd think
that if these people are true public
servants that they would be out there
every single day explaining why we have
to
in effect ruin your livelihoods and yet
they don't it's just that every few
weeks they just give us a new edict of
how we have to behave well it looks like
we've run out of time but i would like
to have
uh dr mercola talk just uh
and end this by saying well what about
medical scientists
started with neil ferguson in the uk
dr fauci in the u.s both of them
still seem to be alarmists
nothing has changed they want the
lockdown to continue
indefinitely why what is in the
self-interest
of the medical profession to
to want to solve this problem right away
i mean they are pro-vaccine but it does
seem like it's taking
forever for this vaccine and i'm not
sure the vaccine solves the problem
solves the symptoms maybe but not the
problem well vaccine is no way is going
to solve the problem because
normally it takes about nine years or so
to put it through the the rigorous
trials to exclude any
side effects and this one is going at a
fraction of a fraction of that time
so it's inevitable it could be a
disaster just like the swine flu vaccine
in 1977 that preceded this
which literally had to be stopped after
was encouraged by the government and
three billion dollars was awarded but
what most physicians
if they're going into health care to
help people
their true desire is to literally
support them unfortunately they're no
different than
anyone else and they've been brainwashed
manipulated the whole narrative in
medical school and i know because i went
is directed at literally suppressing
these types of natural therapies that
abuse
been uses for ages that anything that
conflicts with
the pharmaceutical paradigm is
suppressed so and that was done in
1910 by the carnegie report report that
literally kicked out these natural
therapies like homeopathy and other
strategies so
uh it's difficult for them to get
anything other than
than the main narrative and they're so
busy taking care of their patients and
other things they don't have time to
explore these
details uh in the in the the amount of
time they need to to
gain the understanding and proper
perspective and the wisdom so
uh but ultimately we want to preserve
that and interestingly dr faulco you
mentioned
uh reluctantly capitulated that even he
takes vitamin d
so again that stopcoveredcold.com
gives you all the information it's free
there's no email sign them to stop
clovercold.com so
you can get these more information on
what you can do
to protect yourself your families and
your loved ones from this illness
great well we want to thank you guys for
for joining us
and we are going to throw to a
commercial from the capital research
center
covet 19 has drastically changed the
lives of millions of american children
though children are substantially less
likely to be harmed by a coveted
infection
schools across the nation have shut down
over the pandemic and keeping kids at
home doesn't just affect them
but entire families 56 of parents are
concerned about missing work if their
child's school is closed
and 43 are concerned about making up for
the free or reduced-priced meals
that their child received at school
despite the difficulties families
experienced in the spring
it looks like schools across the nation
will remain closed or in limited
capacity in the fall
despite the american academy of
pediatrics strongly advocating that all
policy considerations
for the coming school year should start
with the goal of having students
physically present in school
unfortunately the teachers unions are
forcing schools to stay closed
that's power they shouldn't have
all right our next half hour discussion
is on the question
is america on the brink of political
and economic collapse normally i would
think that would be a bit of an alarmist
question but i'm actually not sure after
watching the debate last night
we've got a couple great guests here but
i have to handle the intro
for the first guy myself uh the man i've
dubbed the willy wonka
of politics michael malus is america
crumbling
you're one of the only guys i trust
absolutely and it's absolutely glorious
um and i think far more than the debate
what
brought about the civil war and american
self-segregation at that time was the
dred scott decision
uh before dred scott you have the idea
that the south
was slave the north was free and they
basically had a gentleman's agreement
each side doesn't bother each other dred
scott's master takes him from
slave soil missouri to free soil
illinois he sues to get his freedom
uh and the supreme court finds no even
if you're a slave on free soil
you are still a slave which means
slavery is everywhere
in america and this was a huge problem
for the north
this is regarded historically as one of
the worst supreme court decisions of all
time
and after that it was a series of
dominoes we are at a point for the first
time
since the civil war in my view where the
supreme court's legitimacy
is about to be regarded as illegitimate
where there is not a consensus that like
you know what
maybe we're going to lose this one but
you know in in the main
it's a good idea to have a supreme court
it's becoming so politicized
uh by both sides that this is going to
in my view hopefully uh lead the way
towards a systemic american separation
malice not only do i love you because of
your british brilliant political insight
but also because you keep a picture of
yourself behind you
that's me on your show that's a from
though bishop from the muse institute
with the red pills
very nice very nice mark who do you want
to introduce next
okay so we have ramesh uh panura right
did i say that correctly
and you did you're with national review
and of course i knew bill buckley
personally for many years a good friend
of mine
you're with national review uh national
review
is officially anti-trump correct
no uh we were against trump during the
2016 primaries we've got a range of
views
on our editorial staff one of the last
places where you can still find
people just arguing things out inside
one publication
well that's good to hear for sure now we
also have
kevin hassett who is the former chairman
of
economic advisers to president trump
so we assume you are pro-trump even
after leaving office but now that you've
left
office and you are are you with aei
or let's see is uh i'm trying i used to
be at aei but now now i'm at uh hoover
that's right with hoover are you in
california right now is that the
background
it looks like no i i'm actually a little
depressed because i'm stuck in dc and i
was supposed to be out there this
semester and so i remind myself of where
i should be with
virtual background yes indeed background
we have matt welch uh and he's the
editor at large
i love that that's kind of like the term
diplomat or something
uh it sounds like you can uh like the
hoover institution you're paid to think
is that uh an accurate way of describing
you
i just wish that i had the uh immunity
to come with it
and can run through all the uh the
traffic light cameras here in brooklyn
uh but yes editor at large is the best
way to describe me for
reason magazine well uh so that covers
all four of our
characters i would like to start with uh
uh
with kevin hassett because uh as an
economist
um i don't know if you watched the
debate last night or not if you could
handle the hour and a half
uh brawl
boy how do you deal with the president
that is constantly
uh agitating and
is he aggressive like that in person and
what's your perspective on this did you
i mean all the election
betting odds say that uh biden won this
debate overwhelmingly
how do you see it right well i think
that
the election markets presumably were
thinking that there was a chance
that joe biden would have a complete
meltdown
and he absolutely did not do that and
you know i i think that if you look at
the substance
for me the headline of the debate was
that there are a lot of things that
biden refused to do to separate himself
from
things that i think moderate voters are
afraid of and so
like the green new deal is a terrifying
policy
that would really destroy the country
and uh you know he's willing to pack the
court he's willing to kill the
filibuster and
i think that that's like the substantive
news from last night but i know
that it's hard to focus on the
substantive news given all the fireworks
yes indeed uh i'd i'd be curious
what uh are what matt and uh
renish uh uh ramish what you
thought of the debate could you handle
it emotionally
uh survive or is will you ever watch
another debate after this one is it even
worth your time
uh alcohol is a marvelous marvelous uh
drug mark as we all know um yeah i have
to watch it for a living
you know i wouldn't otherwise uh at all
um
it was a viscerally unpleasant
television and arguably exactly
uh what we deserve as a country i think
it's an accurate reflection
of how lousy and stupid our politics are
and will be
probably for a generation i'm not a
catastrophist
uh cheerfully or otherwise like uh my
friend michael malus for whom i i always
disagree with
very very cautiously um because he's
probably right and i'm probably wrong
but
um i think it's more you know is johnny
rotten that great
maga hat wearer uh once sang about the
uk we're just
another country i think that's what we
have been seeing over the last
especially five years
and what we will probably see for the
next 15 is that
american exceptionalism um for good and
for bad and
it's been both um is uh you know we're
doing the same stuff that hungary is
doing
god help us we're doing the same stuff
that a hell of a lot of countries are
doing right now we're getting into this
kind of crabby populism right now the
governing
crabby populism is of the right we will
at some point
soon get crabby populism of the left and
it will be bad
at every level of government i live in
new york city
my god we are governed by boobs and
incompetence here
it is amazing to behold i don't see any
sanctuary of good governance in this
country and i don't see any promise
of a sanctuary of good governance for
this country the people who are trying
to backfill
men like create some kind of ideological
uh wish casting on
trumpism and hope to replace him um the
tom cottons of the worlds the john
josh hollies of the worlds um they are
from my point of view and ramesh will
probably disagree
um nightmares too and i don't see
anything
really good happening from it the best
thing we could say about joe biden
which really we can't say any really
good thing about joe biden
is that he's a rusty weather vane right
like he creaks
slowly in the direction of the
prevailing winds so at least
it won't go fast into the green new deal
but that's about it
matt uh i know that oh uh dave did you
want to say something
yeah well i i want to get to ramesh on
that because i think it's it's an
interesting question
um what you brought up right there which
is sort of that biden is like
the the bulwark the sort of rusty
bulwark
against the radical leftism and how
quickly will that break
and i think a lot of people thought oh
he's going to get on stage last night
and just
melt down and then it'll show that
they're about you know that the radical
leftists are here
that didn't quite happen um but but your
second point on
you know these guys behind trump is
there sort of an
intellectual backing behind trump i'm
kind of hopeful for that
ramesh what do you think well
uh first of all let me say my hat's off
to kevin hassett who has found a virtual
background that is a perfect match for
his personality
um i asked the question about whether
i'll watch another debate again
yes but not with children present
i would like to see better examples set
for them
i think what i saw last night was
not um a the picture of the political
leadership of a country
that is about to undergo collapse but
one that
is undergoing decay uh and you can see
that partly
in the kind of gerontocracy that we saw
on display and you can see it as well i
think in the way both
parties have been running away
at maybe different speeds from free
markets limited government the rule of
law
and other such principles that have made
our country great in joe biden's case
he has always been somebody who goes
where the mainstream of the democratic
party
is he doesn't lead it he follows it and
that mainstream of the democratic party
has been moving left the online left
overestimated just how far left it was
during the primaries
and backed a bunch of left-wing
candidates who had the same
misunderstanding
but if you remove the sort of distortion
field of twitter
then i think you have to objectively
look at biden's platform and
say it is the most left-wing progressive
and statist
that we've seen from any democrat for
quite a long time
and i think you can see also that
biden's having a little trouble
navigating
these currents you could see it in the
space of a couple minutes
last night when he when he said i don't
support the green new deal
the green new deal will pay for itself
by creating
thousands of jobs i don't support the
green new deal
um that was one of the closest things he
had last night
to a senior moment but then which by the
way according to his own website he does
support the green dude
that's right that's right he you know
his own the by joe biden.com
says um you know the green the green new
deal is the right framework
um but when you look at trump you don't
see somebody who
is um you know let's say an evangelist
for free markets
uh and whose instincts on trade
insurance instincts on drug prices are
not
always aligned with free markets not
always in my view
based in reality and so i think that
those of us
who do think that there's a lot to be
said for free markets and a lot more
opportunities for america
to seize using them we really have our
work cut out for us
i'd like to mention uh one a couple of
things that joe biden said that i
thought
trump could have responded to if he was
truly a free-market one and that
that is when joe biden said uh donald
trump does not have a plan
when it comes to health care and of
course lazy
if we're laissez-faire we we're not sure
we should have a
plan per se but you know he could have
said
uh kevin uh health savings accounts
he could have referred to singapore's
medisave program that has been highly
successful
there's lots of example perhaps even
other countries may have
medical systems that work better were
you disappointed kevin
when donald trump never responded to
having a plan for health care which is a
major issue among voters
right you know i i think that there were
a number of points
where he could have said something about
what he's done and his accomplishments
in it
even to be a little responsive to what
ramesh said
uh like because of free markets and
competition being brought into
healthcare
uh through you know myriad regulatory
changes that we made while i was still
over there
we did things for example like accept
the gazillion
uh generic drugs which made it so the
consumer price index for drugs
in the us declined uh two years in a row
and each of those declines were the
first decline since world war
ii and it was because there was so much
more competition in healthcare markets
and so
i think that that's an example of well
of course i have a plan but my plan is
to make it cheaper he did say that
but he could have given a better example
but there were a lot of cases like that
and i just want to like give you an
example that uh you might remember
that like when we were selling the tax
cuts i wasn't on tv all the time the
president's off
tv all the time promising that they
deliver four thousand dollars
in uh wages because if you have more
jobs you have a higher demand for labor
and it drives up wages
and it would do that in three to five
years well you know in 2019 alone we got
the data last week
then wages went up by forty three
hundred dollars just in that year alone
for the median family
and in the eight years of biden and
obama the median wage only went up by
thirteen hundred dollars for the whole
eight years
last year alone it tripled the whole
eight years of buying nova
so so the point is if i were debating uh
you know i would have been
laying all over the the points like that
and i think that that he didn't do that
he made a tactical decision basically i
think
to litigate stuff that the mainstream
medias refused to litigate
you know like bringing up the you know
the director of national intelligence
released yesterday some documents that
showed that
the oh the obama administration was
warned that hillary clinton was planned
to set
trump up with a fake russia hoax right
and things like that like so all of that
stuff and the hunter biden stuff
is something that you just don't hear
about at all in the mainstream media and
i guess he decided he had to litigate
all that stuff because it was the way to
get the message through
so malice as i was watching this last
night i
kept thinking i'm looking through
twitter and i'm looking at everybody
and everybody's saying this is
depressing this is awful there were very
few people even
even the pure partisans weren't saying
oh my guy absolutely won
i mean everybody was saying this thing
was a disaster and chris wallace was
terrible
and the whole thing of course you get
some of the partisans but for the most
part that was the general takeaway
and i kept thinking i'm looking forward
to talking to malice tomorrow because if
someone's enjoying this it's got to be
it's got to be michael malus because
this is sort of what you want to happen
i think can you explain exactly why that
is
sure it's uh those who need leaders are
not qualified to choose them
so if you're sitting there as a voter
and you don't know anything about
politics
and these are the two choices you have
if you don't even speak english
if you're looking at how these men are
carrying themselves their posture their
body language
they're both you know not acceptable as
someone who's going to make decisions
over
whether my wife has a kid going to war
and all these other things simply due to
their body language
i think they were both debating in very
different ways
one of the things that joe biden
represents very well the you know the
american argument for having democracy
over aristocracy
was after a while the aristocrats kind
of inbreed and you get something like
the habsburg jaw
where you have this kind of low hanging
jaw that people can't even talk and
there's no better example of this than
joe biden
who was one second away from literally
voiding his bowels at all times
on the other hand you have president
trump who's just like barking like an
attack dog
and he and it was the they should have
called him jeb biden
because it was the and i think at one
point he did call him jeb the body
language and the aggression was
completely off the charts
and if you're looking at it from one of
these like kind of like sociological
aspects it is that kind of like who is a
very very
old-school business approach like the
proverbial trump handshake where he
grabs people calls them
where you have one guy owning the room
and kind of putting his you know what on
the desk
and showing them who's boss now that
might work on wall street but in this
context where there's soccer moms
i don't think it played necessarily well
for him but there sure were a lot of
good sound bites
at uh joe biden's expense and he
wouldn't even make eye contact
with trump which just shows you how to
win a man is weak
yeah uh go ahead i was gonna say uh dave
and uh michael speaking of body language
uh biden did a good job of pandering
and in a sense he yeah he looked right
at the camera
he smiled uh in large
major he was he was polite there were
some exceptions but
trump clearly was the aggressor and
constantly interrupting he embarrassed
himself
i i was embarrassed i think a lot of
people were embarrassed by that
uh what what do you think of the the the
fact that biden
smiled looked into the camera it seems
like that's
the way politicians should act what what
is the problem with trump he couldn't
even smile the entire time he had a
grumpy look on his face
the entire hour and a half
alice can i can i let me give let me
give it 20 seconds and then i want you
to answer this so
my take on the biden smile is that it's
very inauthentic
actually it's whenever trump made what i
thought was a pretty decent point
biden just smiled it off which is
something hillary would do you just
laugh it off as if it has no meaning
so when when trump brought up you know
hunter and the 3.5 million
biden's laughing as if it has no meaning
as opposed to addressing it which we
know
it's an actual issue but i think just
one other thing on this which is that
trump coming in so angry and so
indignant it sort of works when you're
not president but when you are president
it hit me in the middle of it i was
actually expecting him to act a little
more presidential last night
which i very rarely ask him to do malice
what do you think
if you go back and look at iran the
great vampire novelist on donahue in
1980 her second appearance she discusses
this exact thing vis-a-vis jimmy carter
she says if you watch i'm not gonna do
her accent here if you watch jimmy
carter
he smiles even when things are supposed
to be serious it's like a nervous tick
and she makes the face she goes oh gosh
i forgot him on tv
so i think it's a very corporate thing
to do when someone is saying things that
are very scurrilous about you this
happened with tulsi
and camel harris tell us he's like look
there was a guy on death row you had his
dna you didn't want to be released and
she's like
it's like okay why are you laughing if
even if tulsi is full of crap
why this isn't funny this is something
very serious you're being accused of
and to signal that this is something be
serious
is affected with some members of the
audience but in terms of people who have
some
understanding of politics and the facts
it's kind of disquieting
so um if i could jump in on this just
two things that struck me is different
between trump and 2016 and trump now
trump often in 2016 seemed to be
enjoying himself
on the campaign trail and i and i don't
think he felt
you didn't get that last night you get
the sense that he enjoyed
being an insurgent challenger in a way
he doesn't enjoy running
as an incumbent the second thing is in
2016 he talked about a lot of
issues that mattered to a lot of voters
but weren't being discussed by political
elites immigration being one
manufacturing jobs the opioid crisis
i feel like he's spending a lot less
time talking about those sorts of issues
he didn't bring up immigration once
the media is not going to do it for him
if he doesn't do it himself
and he talked about a bunch of stuff
that
is more of interest to him than it is to
large groups of voters um and frankly i
think the hunter biden thing is an
example of that because it's the sort of
thing
people who are totally revved up in his
corner know about this issue
if they're not in his corner already
he's got to explain what it's about
he's got to explain why they should care
about it he's not talking about the
stuff
they already come into the debate caring
about so matt uh maybe that gets us to
uh the issue of who's going to win in
november
uh since he didn't really trump didn't
pander to the michigan
and wisconsin and uh
pennsylvania and those battle uh states
uh is easy destined to lose the election
voting odds uh increased dramatically
dramatically to 60 this morning
on election bidding uh uh bidding odds
uh betting odds uh do you see any chance
that the
silent uh uh the secret ballot is going
to
uh elect donald trump or re-elect donald
trump
are you seriously asking a journalist
let alone a libertarian journalist
to accurately forecast an election yes
yes
you're on the spot here uh listen the
one
one thing that uh that i'll say in this
kind of uh touches to the uh the comedy
question comedy works best when you
you know insult comedy in particular and
donald trump is the funniest
president maybe that we've had at least
that uh ronald reagan had some good
timing too but trump is an insult comic
and he's very very skilled at it which
his detractors hate to admit
but part of that depends on um wrong
footing or my god i can't believe that
he had
the cajones to say that in a political
context
where there's supposed to be this sort
of other rules about engagement and
that's thrilling
when you're the insurgent when you're
the outsider it is not thrilling when
you know what's coming when you know
that's what he what he does when he's
the president
that's a challenge he has a hard time
running he has to run
against the record of himself which is a
little bit uh awkward so
um this has been an unusually stable
race 90 to 95 percent
of voters made up their mind six months
ago
uh they're really i mean the number of
undecideds the number of third party
supporters is really vanishingly small
and when you look at their preferences
of those
people um now you know big poll came out
a couple of weeks back something like 47
percent of people who go to third party
in 2016
compared to something like 20 something
a percent uh said that they want to vote
for joe biden this time around there's i
mean people are coming back to the
two-party fold
to vote against the other bad guy uh and
right now that energy including for
independence
um which is double-digit percentage of
in favor of biden
um and i think third-party voters is all
trending biden
and that the stability of the race has
been just been remarkable it's been
between
nationally between six and a half and
nine percentage points basically the
last three or four months
it's hard to see anything including last
night uh including
we've had a pandemic in the meantime
it's not a small thing um that hasn't
if you look at the line of the race it
hasn't moved anything so
what could possibly move people move
that last remaining nub of people who
were
persuadable to uh come out i don't i
don't know that there is such a thing
and so
uh absent that thing it's going to be
really hard for donald trump to win
well i think all all he has to do is
promise to new california
and he'd win 50 states because even the
californians would be like well it's
tough but fair
yeah well kevin uh i think one of the
things that we on wall street really
appreciate is gridlock
uh but it the way the
betting is now the democrats are going
to sweep
in november if that happens
uh what where's the economy going i mean
chris wallace he came up with this
crazy statistic that you're going to
increase
jobs and and all kinds of economic
growth
uh through these high tax high spending
policies
uh one thing i did think joe biden
uh did bring up that i thought was
pretty good uh
or chris wallace did are we going to
have a v-shape recovery
or a k-shaped recovery i thought that
was a really good question because some
people are being left behind
i know my my daughter and her son-in-law
my son-in-law they're both unemployed
they worked on cruise ships
restaurants are going under there's so
there is that k
going on in the economy entertainment is
down
publishing is down uh meanwhile
technology and online and amazon are
going through the roof
uh is the is the is the economy a k
recovery or a b
recovery what's your what's your view
you know i
i think that the the really big question
is
is biden actually going to pursue the
policies that he's embraced in order to
get the left to support him
and um at national review over the next
week or two we're going to be going into
a lot of work that casey mulligan at the
university of chicago and i have been
doing
on this but there's just so much stuff
that they've proposed
that is humongously harmful to the
economy and i'll just give you an
example
that they're increasing the payroll tax
uh for people above 400
000 so or they're exposing all income
above 400 000
uh to the payroll tax which is a 12
percentage point
increase in uh the tax rate for small
businesses that employ
more than 40 million people right and so
it's like one of the most catastrophic
proposals that i think anyone's ever
seen in terms of the economic harm that
would cause immediately
and nobody's even talking about it and
and so i think the question is does he
actually pursue that stuff or does he
not
and i think that if he does then there's
no telling how bad the economy will get
casey and i are going to estimate
that the reduction in gdp is going to be
in the 8 to 10
range uh once you like aggregate all his
policies and look at the economic effect
wow were you guys all expecting biden to
just collapse i think partly
what happened last night was that
everyone expected biden to just implode
and i think partly why trump
was so angry and sort of off-kilter
right from the beginning is he went in
for the the knockout punch right at the
beginning and i think when it didn't
happen and when biden surprisingly
was able to string some sentences
together without losing his place
and it only happened once or twice and
on some pretty minor stuff
i think uh trump didn't really have
a backup move which was let's okay we
got a dance we got to do this for a
couple of rounds
and he just kept going and going and
going it and it never came around
what kind of we should have asked dr
mccola what kind of uh
pills joe biden was taking to
the uppers to keep him uh
doing really well i agree with you he
did not blunder at all really
well i think it's yeah what do you guys
think of that i think it's crazy the
extent to which the trump campaign team
has spent the last five months trying to
um sell the idea that biden is a senile
drooling [ __ ] if that's the case you
let biden
make the case that that's true you let
biden's talk
uninterrupted and let him show that
that's true
you don't lower expectations for him and
set the bar
so low that he's bound to exceed them in
practice
and that's what they've done i think
it's been a real strategic blunder on
the part of the trumpet
and like if it's going to be about like
uh oral skills oral presentation
uh uh it's that's gonna be kind of a
wash people i mean
it's not that i think trump is
cognitively sharper
than than joe biden but like he doesn't
clean up very well
you don't want to invite him home for
thanksgiving you know
it's like he doesn't know how to behave
right like i don't
there are people i know who exist in the
world who said you know
that's how i think that behavior should
be in the in in the real world
there are some but they're not many
right so like if you're going to make
kind of uh your presentation skills a
big thing
i don't know man uh he's it just in the
same way that you know having donald
trump as your salesman for
anti-socialism
how about someone who didn't grow the
size of the annual federal budget
by nearly a trillion dollars in 47
months
yeah it's really funny to have trump
attack sorry the green new deal it's
four trillion dollars
when he's spending two trillion so two
trillions reasonable but four trillion's
insane
it's it's a it's not a lot of
credibility there
well malice as the as the guy who gets
the the trolls more than anybody maybe
except for trump were you surprised that
he didn't have a backup move that he
didn't have
some sort of oh i didn't knock him off
in this first half hour i better change
tactics at some point
no i think i'm not the only one to point
out and i'm sure kevin has experienced
this on a personal level that donald
trump is pretty much pure aid
um and that he only does have very few
tactics we've seen him restrain himself
at various times like during the
kavanaugh hearings he kind of held his
tongue
and there were certain other instances
but i think on a very visceral level
uh he has that new yorker's contempt for
people that he proceeds are
weak so if he's yelling at this man in
his face and saying just really
scurrilous things
and bind won't even look at him and it's
just kind of laughing it off
i think in a very visceral level it
triggered him to just go harder and
harder and harder it's like come on
stand up for yourself because this is
someone who
you know by all accounts when he would
find some blog making fun the apprentice
would have meetings
and would talk for 15 minutes ranting
like do you think this is true and
people couldn't wrap their heads around
the fact that he cared that some random
jerk on the internet had a
negative opinion of him so i think
that's what we were seeing there and
then
once
his own experience here the only one
who's really spent a lot of time with
trump
although i understand that you were uh
you were not always in the in the room
so to speak that he didn't he didn't
really like economists is this true
well that's just not true no good i'm
sure i saw him about as much as anybody
in the two years that i was there
the the thing i could say uh about like
and so now i'm not excusing uh
rude behavior because i hope you've
never seen me engage in it i don't know
maybe i have
so certainly privately to remesh but
but but you know i i think that one of
the dynamics that was interesting was
the
the vice president biden was saying
things that were just patently pulsed
uh and then wallace was not saying well
wait a minute you know that's disproven
things like that and so then trump was
interrupting to so no wait a minute i
didn't actually
say that or you know that's your you
know you're taking it out of context
there were so many of those whereas uh
you know
you got to admit that the moderator was
interrupting president trump and saying
no wait a minute
that's not true you know there's no
problem at all with mail and voting even
though
we actually have like convictions that
you could actually go and there's a
website where you click on the state and
you can see all the mail and voting
convictions and there's many
in many states now i'm not saying it's a
conspiracy a national conspiracy to
steal an election
but the idea that you know worrying
about fraud and mail-in ballots given
that we've you know
found uh in new jersey the mailbox
filled with hundreds of them and so on
it's just it's a reasonable thing to
have the moderator basically sort of say
oh no
that's that's that's just discredited as
disproven that's the kind of night that
he was having and i think that he was
getting very frustrated with that and i
think getting frustrated is probably not
a good
debate tactic but it is astonishing how
many just
false things that pres the vice
president biden said right at the
beginning and then
you know in terms of the projection the
democrats do he then turns and calls the
president a liar left and right right
yeah and
very quickly just want to say we keep
talking about the importance of intel
preserving the integrity of this
election and then as soon as he brings
it up it's like oh that's ridiculous
there's no problems it's like well which
is it
yeah right or even you know the critical
race theory question
when wallace framed it it was as if
critical race theory
is anti-racism but if you've been paying
any attention to it it's actually
instilling racism
in our institutions and and i think
trump sort of faltered there
because he's not the greatest explainer
of ideas and then he got hung up
on on this white supremacy line and that
seems to be from what i saw this morning
that seems to be the thing everybody's
uh getting caught up on he's also not
the greatest haver of ideas dave i think
it is a problem here i'm not sure if
he understands the what's happening in
the in the ibram candy universe
right but but again think about this
that we right now if we were going to
think about like what are the top five
things if you got to interview joe biden
that you would push him on you know then
none of those came up
none of them not one right and and then
when when they did ask him like so so
would you
uh stack the supreme court and do away
with the filibuster he refused to answer
he said oh i'm not going to talk about
that because then everyone's going to
talk about matters about what he said
right
and then wallace just let it go he just
let it go i mean talk about being in the
tank for somebody
i mean i thought it was disgusting and
it's something that we've seen in every
republican debate forever and ever and
ever
you just go back and look you know
george stephanopoulos asking about
taking away contraception and so on
and so so i think that it really is a
problem uh in the debates and i think
it's one reason why
uh trump has sort of burst through with
his super aggressive behavior
because people recognize that the
moderators are in the tank for the
democrats
uh to defend chris wallace for a second
i i dispute that he's in the tank
i think he did a lousy job last night i
think that pretty much everybody would
have done a lousy job last night
who isn't uh intimately familiar with
world wide wrestling or something
but like uh uh i don't think that he's
in the tank i think he's a serious
journalist who had a bad night
he well he had a bad night okay so so
why was he just so
deferential to biden and not even asking
you many tired questions
and then when he got let me just jump
you know he just dropped it
you know i mean i mean biden cannot be
allowed to get away with this excuse
that it's a distraction before the
election
yeah to talk about his plans for after
dealing yeah that's what an election is
supposed to be about
and that that excuse on court packing
works
for any inconvenient issue that any
candidate doesn't want to talk about
it is just the most transparent thing
i've ever seen yeah
well i think that's probably the perfect
segue
for our next guest who is that third
party you know there is this third party
still in america that libertarian party
so
we're gonna jump to joe jorgensen uh but
thank you guys
thank you guys for joining us today
take care all right so let's throw to
libertarian presidential candidate joe
jorgensen
i got the love of our country from my
grandmother she instilled in me the
american values
and explained how great it was and she
knew how great america was
because she was an immigrant she
explained that in the old country it
didn't matter how hard you work
it didn't matter if you worked a second
or third job because the government took
everything extra away from you
because the government wanted everybody
to have the same
now listening to her she sounds like
maybe she was from
the soviet union or an eastern bloc
country
actually she was from denmark and
unfortunately
we're moving more towards denmark every
day it was my grandmother's vision of
liberty
and the basic principles of the
libertarian party that bring me here
today
everywhere i go people tell me their
stories and you know what i hear
the old way just isn't working as your
president
i will get government out of the way so
my grandmother's vision of the american
dream can be a reality for all of us
last night in the first presidential
debate
americans got to hear from only two of
the candidates who will be on the ballot
this november even though there's a
third person who's on the ballot in all
50 states
i'm here to present not just a different
vision but a better vision of what
america
can and should be the vision of freedom
that drew my grandmother to our great
country
when i first joined the libertarian
party movement 40 years ago
i would explain to people that you know
the libertarian party takes the best of
the right
and the left we take the economic
freedoms from the people on the right
and we take the social liberties the
social freedoms from the people on the
left
but i can't say that anymore because i
don't even hear about economic freedoms
from the people on the right and we
certainly didn't hear any last night
and we haven't seen that in the last
four years we didn't hear
any good plans in the debate last night
when it came to health care
despite having over four years to come
up with a plan
and repeatedly promising to do so
president trump has no
explanation of how he would replace
obamacare
meanwhile vice president biden is
planning to double down on that program
which has failed
so many i say it's time for a new way
as i see it the problem with our health
care is that
our insurance isn't actually insurance
at all in
any other industry insurance only pays
for unexpected costs and because of that
costs remain relatively low meanwhile
our health care insurance system pays
for everything
just think of how expensive your car
insurance would be if it paid for gas
oil changes or car washes first of all
you would have absolutely no reason to
shop around for the best gas prices
because you'd simply take out your
little five dollar copay card
in fact you may even go to the nicest
gas station where they give you free
coffee while you wait
and of course the gas stations would
have no reason to compete with each
other because
they could raise prices without you even
knowing it
why they would simply raise them to the
insurance company and the insurance
company would
simply increase your premiums next year
this is exactly what's happened to the
health care system
there's no reason for patients to shop
around for better prices
and so consequently there's no reason
for health care providers to compete on
price
meanwhile insurance companies keep
increasing increasing prices without any
accountability at all
and we're the ones left footing the bill
we have two
examples we can draw from where
something similar to a free market
system works
both in singapore and the state of
indiana
in both systems people pay for health
care out of their own pockets
of everyday costs and they leave
the catastrophic care only to the health
care insurance
i remember donald trump saying decades
ago
that when it came to getting woman rink
done what he did was he went and looked
to see where they had done it
successfully so he went to the canadians
and asked them hey
how do you get a skating rink done and
he got it done so why doesn't he do the
same thing for health insurance
all we have to do is look to singapore
and see a successful system so why
doesn't he go there and follow their
system
and by the way they use insurance for
catastrophic costs only
their costs are only a third of what
they are here
and doctor visits only cost ten dollars
each which is less than our co-pay
and by the way the state of indiana has
a similar system
we've got an example out there why
doesn't donald trump use it
if i were president i would go with what
works i would go with success and
recreate it for our country
when it comes to kovic 19 again neither
candidate was able to articulate a real
policy
president trump's fda has stood in the
way of expanding testing
south korea confirmed its first
coronavirus case within a
day of our first case and quickly jumped
ahead in testing
containing the spread without a lockdown
meanwhile the first company to create
tests in the u.s that could be conducted
outside
of hospitals was stopped when the fda
said they needed
quote unquote further assessment when i
am your president
i will get rid of the efficacy
requirement of the fda
if not the fda entirely on the other
hand
vice president biden's solution is to
institute national mandates
in a pandemic like this it is best for
communities and families
not the federal government to be making
decisions on their health
both the democrats and the republicans
send the message that if the government
doesn't do it
then it won't get done that's why
they're telling us that we need to wear
masks
however walmart and other stores have
proven them wrong
walmart came out and said if anybody
comes to our store
they need to wear a mask and other
stores followed suit rather than having
a one-size-fits-all from the government
like biden and trump
want how about having each person decide
every day
each day allow us to vote with our feet
or vote with our dollars
if we want to wear a mask we go to the
stores that have
masks such as walmart and the other
stores if we don't want to wear a mask
let us vote with our feet vote with our
dollars for the other stores
on the economy both candidates offered
more of the same
it is individuals in the private sector
working together
innovating and creating who create
booming economies
government needs to just get out of the
way
in fact the same money in private hands
creates twice
as many jobs as in the government hands
the president did however
make an important point about the tax
code he pointed out that the tax system
is so complicated
that only the wealthy and connected such
as himself
can navigate the codes with fancy tax
accountants
vice president biden's solution is
simply to raise taxes
which will ultimately be paid by
hardworking american families
i propose something different i will
eliminate the irs
and work with congress towards
eliminating the federal income tax
altogether i want every american to pay
as little in taxes as president trump
did
vice president biden meanwhile attempted
to promote economic protectionism
through tariffs and invoking the mantra
of bi-american
unfortunately this is following in the
footsteps of president trump i'm
so sad to be the only free trade
candidate in this election
but i am very proud to be a free trade
candidate
trade boosts the prosperity of both
united states
and our world neighbors because of
specialization across
nations countries exchange not just
final products
but intermediate products that create
goods
the expansion of trade over the last 70
years has resulted in an average of
eighteen
thousand dollars towards each american
family
benefiting those who are the poorest the
best
as president i will dismantle all
tariffs and any other trade barriers
which prevent the flow of goods and
services in and out of the country
americans deserve the best and it
doesn't matter where the best may come
on the issue of climate change vice
president biden meanwhile proposed a
top-down government mandate
including a stop to new coal or oil
factories
i propose something different to address
this important issue
i will work with congress to end all
energy subsidies
and level the playing field additionally
we must reduce barriers which
entrench existing sources such as fossil
fuels
to prevent competition and innovation
which can help create cleaner energy
the most promising form of energy is
nuclear
with the carbon footprint vastly
outmatched by its efficiency
ironically the candidates were also
asked to comment on the integrity of
this election
in any other country we view with
disdain the censoring of political
opponents
but it has become accepted practice here
why was i denied the opportunity to
speak to millions of americans
i think i know why because i would give
the only choice
the only alternative to big government i
see america through my grandmother's
eyes
a place where the rights of the
individual are greater than the power of
government
a place where liberty means minimum
government and maximum freedom
a place where the american dream isn't a
dream at all it's real and it's right
there in front of you
because you made it happen thank you
well ladies and gentlemen uh friends of
freedomfest
and uh the dave rubin show we welcome
you back
to uh another great session of our
emergency meeting
here at freedom fast co-host here
with dave rubin and this session is on
american education
and the importance of the cultural
changes that we're seeing
as a result of the events of 2020
and we have with us three
uh great experts we have corey d'angelis
who's the director of public choice
at reason foundation and i understand
has been nominated you may not even know
this corey but you've been nominated
for the forbes 30 under 30 list
so that would be really cool if you made
something like that
we also have carrie mcdonald who is the
senior education fellow
at fee the foundation for economic
education i was president of fee
back in 2001-2002
kerry it's a real pleasure to have you
with us
and then last but not least conor boyack
who
runs the libertas foundation in utah the
only real libertarian think tank
in utah and is making great uh great
progress there and the author of the uh
tuttle twins uh turtle twins right the
turtle trolls i think is that
oh you had it right huddle twins oh
total twins okay
the tunnel twins maybe i was reading
that wrong
but uh it's just great to have you uh
all with us and uh uh so
dave do you want to ask the first
question do you want to get
yeah well let's do a little segue from
our
our previous segment which was about the
debate last night one of the thoughts
that kept popping up in my mind
is that we have a real education problem
here it seems like the issues that we're
talking about many of them
are either framed wrong or dis discussed
in a in a completely backwards way
because we don't even know what we're
talking about
so let's just let's just do sort of
education 101 here
um what is wrong with the system right
now
something is deeply wrong corey we've
talked about it a little bit on
on the twitter machine before so i'll go
to you first yeah well traditional
public schools have a geographic
monopoly because of residential
assignment
in k-12 level in the united states and
they have additional monopoly power
through compulsory
property tax funding and so i think
that's a lot of what we're seeing with
problems with the school reopening
debate right now
you look at the private businesses
private schools private
day cares private grocery stores they're
all either
reopened already or they're fighting to
reopen whereas you have far too many
public schools fighting to remain
closed right now or they're just not
reopening for business for
their customers and i think the main
difference here is one of incentives one
of these sectors gets your money
regardless of how
well they meet the needs of their
customers
yeah that kind of gets to the heart of
it and then and then it seems like half
of our politicians don't
don't want school choice at all so we've
we've got several problems there
kerry what do you think yeah i would
agree with corey
i would also say that parents are really
not
empowered when it comes to education and
i think if there's one good thing that's
coming come out of the pandemic
it's been to put parents back in charge
of their children's education
to give them an opportunity perhaps that
they haven't had before
to look under the lid of what's going on
in their children's schools
and now to demand more options more
choice
ed choice last year did a survey of
parents finding that while more than 80
percent of children in the us
attend an assigned district school fewer
than 30 percent of their parents
prefer them there so there's a massive
choice gap in american education
that i think has an opportunity to be
closed now
so carrie uh one follow-up question
um homeschooling
is homeschooling now in a major bull
market
and uh it it's kind of like the
public sector blew this opportunity
because homeschooling has now become a
popular thing
yes homeschooling has skyrocketed uh
over the past several months of course
last march when schools in the u.s shut
down
in the wake of the pandemic and the
lockdowns more than 50 million
u.s students found themselves learning
at home
sort of coercive homeschooling or
pandemic homeschooling
but what we found just in a recent
gallup poll a few weeks ago
was that the rate of independent
homeschooling parents
choosing to pull their children out of
school for independent homeschooling
has more than doubled since last year so
parents really are taking
charge realizing that they have much
more freedom
and flexibility and autonomy with
independent homeschooling
forming pandemic pods and micro schools
with other families
and pursuing different kinds of creative
education options
that i think not only will get parents
through this difficult time in the
pandemic but will really
uh stay with us post pandemic as well
yeah connor do you view this as a silver
lining to the pandemic that people are
rethinking these things i mean i
i have people in my family that are at
least thinking about homeschooling for
the first time where
if you would have asked them a year ago
no you homeschooling like that
that's not for us 100
you know i saw a funny meme about how
people perceived homeschooling moms
before kovid
right and it was like what was it it was
they were kind of pioneer woman and
these kind of backwater
ladies and how they perceive homeschool
uh women now and they're like wonder
woman and all these like amazing people
we have about a quarter million uh
families in our tuttle twins community
who are reading these books and so we've
done a lot of polling within that
community to say
were you homeschooling are you now what
what are these decisions
uh that you've made what have influenced
them what's been really interesting uh
the the data that we've gotten back from
these
this research that we've done is that
for a lot of these families the decision
homeschooling was nothing that
is new it was nothing spontaneous there
has been this latent
nascent uh disinterest discussed
displeasure
with what they have been having their
children served in public schooling
where cobit really was kind of the straw
that broke the camel's back
and led them to finally you know pooper
get off the pot kind of thing it's time
to make a decision it's time to finally
do what's right by my children i've been
feeling this for a while
yeah we can watch the debate and see the
byproduct of these elected officials and
how
uh substandard that is but when you go
watch those man on the street videos of
like high school students or college
students
they can't even answer basic civic
questions if the if the product of our
public school system
is itself substandard i think what we're
seeing now is a lot of families
reconsidering and being kind of pushed
into making a decision as to what's uh
more optimal for their child and in so
many cases that is something like
homeschooling
why do you guys think that the uh go
ahead mark
yeah i was just going to say that just
because you
go to an upper level college i mean
after all president trump went to the
wharton school
and his vocabulary is not particularly
reflective of
upper-level education um uh
private schools in particular i'm really
worried about private schools i mean i
teach at chapman university
in california and they're losing
millions of dollars and many private
schools are going to go under
so there's no silver lining there does
anybody want to comment
uh corey perhaps uh who would like to
comment about
the private schools and that's that's
that's a big negative if you ask me
i mean a lot of people are also
enrolling in private schools too because
they're seeing that the public schools
aren't even opening as i said at the
beginning the private schools are
fighting to reopen
even though in some places the
government is trying to prevent the
private schools from opening their doors
which really protects the public school
from their competition but yeah we're
seeing a lot of differences some private
schools are losing students some private
schools are seeing more but i think the
main way to fix all this problem
all these problems is to have the
funding follow the child we wouldn't
have a whole national debate about
school reopenings if we already had
school choice
through education savings accounts or
private school vouchers
because then if your school district
didn't reopen in person you could take
your money to a private school and
that's how it should have always been
structured
and i think more and more people are
seeing this and they're leaving the
public school system and they're
wondering why their money isn't
following them to that their household
their pandemic pods or a private school
and the latest polling on this from real
clear education actually found that
support for private school choice
initiatives
that has actually gone up by 10
percentage points
among families who had children in
public schools from 67 percent to 77
percent
so families are really re-envisioning
how school finance should look and i
think that's another silver lining of
this pandemic
that you know families have always
gotten short in the stick when it comes
to k-12 education it's just becoming
clearer now more than ever and the
solution there is
fund the child not the system fund the
child not the institution
we do this with so many other
taxpayer-funded initiatives right with
food stamps the money doesn't go to a
residentially assigned government
grocery store
regardless of your choice with pell
grants at the higher education level the
funding goes to the student and the
student has a choice in the matter
whether to take that to a public or
private university
we should do the exact same thing when
it comes to k-12 education i think this
is making sense to more and more people
so kerry i i suspect you agree with uh
corey's premise there
do you think this is just a messaging
issue i mean this one to me this is like
the republicans have such a huge
opportunity here you know because you've
got
people on the left like elizabeth warren
who are demanding that everyone go to
public school
and just throw more money at public
schools while of course her own children
don't
go to public schools or didn't go to
public schools it seems like there's
such an opportunity
for conservatives republicans
libertarians to say
choice is good charter schools good you
know
credits all of these things they don't
seem to be jumping on it
in a sort of functional way yeah
that's a really good point dave i think
um you know parents
that i've talked to and i'm in liberal
cambridge massachusetts
uh you know typically thought of things
like school choice or vouchers or
education savings accounts as
uh conservative or libertarian you know
political mechanisms
and i think through the pandemic they're
realizing particularly as these pandemic
pods
have been proliferating that you know
gee this is a way
of making education options more
accessible to more families there
shouldn't be anything
political about it i think it's just
makes sense that we have
many more choices for more families and
so this is starting to catch on and i
think it will be
great to see where this goes i think
president trump has been right to be
reinforcing school choice in many of his
speeches of course school choice any
kind of education policy should be at
the state and local level there is
no constitutional role for the federal
government in education
and just to jump in there
are we seeing a permanent cultural
change our children
private or public schools little
children
everybody has to wear a mask everybody
ages in social distance
are we brainwashing our church
what are we teaching our young people
online education uh it's inferior
there's no question about it online
education is inferior i teach
on a college level and i can tell you i
dread
the online experience i have to go
through again in january
or if it's in person i not only have to
wear a mask but i have to have a shield
as a teacher and all the students i
can't see how they smile
i can't see uh the interaction is lost
there
uh what kind of cultural changes are we
seeing
from uh from what's happening in 2020
let me jump in if i can take that one
that was actually a specific question
that we asked our community
trying to understand how much the the
mask and the current circumstances of
schooling
led to the decision of all of these
parents to exit the public school system
we wanted to tease that out and
understand that
what was very interesting is that while
i think it was about two-thirds of
families said that the
the mask mandates were part of their
decision
to leave the public school system they
continually responded yes to every other
question i'm dissatisfied with the
curriculum
i don't like how much they waste time i
don't like that my kids are bullied
i don't like that they come home
depressed my child is changing these are
deep dissatisfactions with the system
itself of which the mask is only maybe
kind of the the tip of the spear
or what is finally causing them to make
some of these decisions more recently
i do think that there are going to be
long-standing social
implications to the way schools are
being set up right now with the mass
just think of the the uh kind of
enculturation of
having children follow orders that they
don't understand
restricting their freedom the
implications of that on things that have
nothing to do with nothing to do with
masks
we are basically breeding a generation
of submissive people
that are going to be pliable to who
knows what down the road um and so
that's why you know every every time i
see on social media some videos some kid
resisting or
you know causing trouble i think yes
finally there's our next ron paul or
something like that someone who can push
back
um and and offer an alternative point of
view because i do think we're going to
have some long-standing
ripple effects of what we're seeing now
i'm hopeful though that there is kind of
the remnant there's a contingent of
people out there who are saying
i am just dissatisfied with what i see
i'm gonna do something else corey's
exactly right we have to figure out the
funding issue
because of all these families that we
talk to that decide to go home school or
private school or pandemic pod or
whatever else
the funding is like the biggest problem
and so many more people
would unshackle themselves from the
status quo if only
they had the ability to make it
financially work with you know having to
work two jobs single mom whatever
it is one of the biggest problems that
if we can figure out they're going to be
huge implications for so many more
people leaving the public school system
and i think that's for the better and by
the way
what you're talking about there is not
just that the idea level i i was
zooming with my or face timing actually
with my
nephew who just started sixth grade and
i asked him if he's made any new friends
because you know it's now they're in
school with other schools that have all
come together and he said well we're in
masks all day nobody really talks to
anybody
and that's just the beginning of this
thing it's like you you remember what
it's like to be in class and to be able
to smile around and joke with a friend
and
that's how you start forming social
bonds and we're stripping that
from them yeah and it's making
homeschooling look better and better
right i think that's why we're seeing so
many
homeschool filings go up all across the
country texas for example
reported a 288 increase in homeschool
filings from the same time last year
i think conor looked up similar numbers
in the largest school district
in uh utah about 175 percent increase so
people are re-envisioning the factory
model of schooling itself they're
re-envisioning
the funding structure of k-12 education
and how it doesn't make any sense and
then they're also seeing a lot of things
that are going on in the classrooms that
they don't really
like all that much with the political
persuasions of some of the teachers for
example and
this one teacher from a pennsylvania
school district i think in philadelphia
was pointing out on twitter that he was
concerned that parents were going to see
what he was teaching the children on the
virtual zoom classrooms
and a lot of conservatives pushed back
because they didn't
they didn't like um how certain teachers
were
were teaching their children uh you know
uh political issues
yeah i would also add too that
entrepreneurs
are taking notice of this increased
demand
of parents for education alternatives
for schooling options
and are really creating some wonderful
new startups
for example there's a company called
school house that
connects certified teachers with
families that want to create these
micro schools or pods i talked to an
entrepreneur this week who's starting a
project-based
virtual school and is really excited by
that because a lot of the parents that
he's spoken to are just completely
dissatisfied
with the remote learning that's
happening in their school districts this
is going to be a low-cost
scalable virtual option so you know i
think we're going to see a lot of
entrepreneurship and innovation coming
out of this pandemic as well
if i could play the devil's advocate a
little bit
one of the things that we're doing in
our country is splintering our
educational system it used to be that
almost everybody went to a public school
there were a few exceptions
i went to a public school when i grew up
i don't think i was particularly hurt by
the education my daughter
went from a private school in florida to
a public school in new york and actually
had a better education she said
so i think a lot of it depends on the
kind of education you get
and yes i'm going to use a term common
core which is a term that you probably
don't like
but there used to be a time when
everybody learned
more or less the same thing in american
education american history
american science and so forth are we
getting to the point where
everybody's going their own way and we
have no
common uh values common culture
that everybody can say oh we're an
american
is that a problem mark i think we are
seeing the manifestation of the late
john taylor gatto's book
dumbing us down the the system itself
has been co-opted yes
in yesteryear you could have kind of
run-of-the-mill
solid education broad-based you know
critical thinking logic and all the rest
we don't have that anymore there there
definitely is
a faction within the public schooling
movement who sees themselves as
revolutionaries
and sees children as clay and they have
co-opted this system for their own
purposes
and so you know we can pine for a day
gone by
when things were better and i agree they
were you know back in the day in media
we had
cbs abc nbc right we just had a few
channels we had actual journalism or
perhaps better journalism
now we have like all kinds of stuff we
have the reuben report that wouldn't
exist back in a day when we only had
three channels so
uh you know are you saying i'm helping
or hurting that was unclear
yeah but you know choice is important we
have decentralization everyone
everyone can kind of find what works for
them the problem that we run into
and this is maybe where things like this
hurt a little bit is it does
encourage tribalism everyone rushes to
their person and we have to figure out
how i can binge listen to ruben report
all day long but still get along with
people
who are listening to you know msnbc or
something we have to let this not
seep into broader social issues which i
think last night's debate
is very uh a good example of that yeah i
find this to be a particularly tough one
for
libertarians uh kerry i'll let you jump
in because if we if we don't want sort
of that monolithic federal structure to
be telling everybody what to do and
every state how to deal with it we want
to hand it
more to the states and more to the local
governments well then we are going to
have that fraying because
realistically what is going to be taught
by radical teachers in san francisco
is probably going to be very different
than say what's taught
in in a rural city in idaho terry
right yeah and you know i just wrote an
article recently for free.org that
talked about
you know if you don't want abide in 1619
commission you should oppose trump's
1776 commission
uh you know the same idea that this that
education really should be at the state
and local levels
that it should be the least coercive
uh possible and you know back to the
the earlier point that mark brings out
you know i think that there's a lot of
promise
in diversity and in choice uh that if we
have sort of forced education
forced patriotism for example that's not
authentic that's not going to help us
out uh you know so the key really is to
make education as decentralized as
parent driven and as student-centered as
possible
well i have a real quick question on
project
1619
is that the new way we're going in terms
of common core
instead of 1776 as an education system
and then my second question is what
about prager university and places like
that is this the future
of libertarian conservative
type of education that we're now going
to get our education
from a online source like prager
university
dennis prager i i think is a friend of
yours right dave
uh yeah that's the future so where are
we going here what do you think of 1699
project and what about prager university
yeah i'll just point out let's go
yeah i don't think 1619 is kind of like
a common core because it's not
mandated from the top down but there are
some school districts that have already
introduced 1619 project
i think buffalo new york and washington
dc have introduced it to their
curriculum
maybe a couple of other places and i i
want to just say the the way to fix this
issue is is not a top-down mandate from
the government you'll never be able to
agree what curriculum is the one best
curriculum for every single traditional
public school in the nation
the only way that we can fix this issue
is to allow families to vote with their
feet
to allow for that bottom-up
accountability and to account for
different
regional differences so school choice is
needed when it comes to curriculum
issues as well and look when it gets to
the
you know kind of political polarization
question from before
we already have about almost 90 percent
of kids in public schools today yet we
already have a politically
uh polarized society today
it could be that the public school
system is leading to to that political
polarization and
in fact if you look at the private
school choice literature if you look at
dr wolf's review of the evidence on this
actually
turns out that when people choose their
schools it leads to better civic
outcomes like tolerance of others views
and it could be because those schools
are better at teaching logic so people
attack the logic of people's arguments
rather than their backgrounds
which leads to a more peaceful and
prosperous society
you know it's interesting uh mark you
brought up prager university or prageru
i mean technically of course it's not an
accredited university but what i've
found
i i've done three of their you know four
or five minute videos
and what i found is these videos that
get seen by millions and millions of
people i think i think the first video i
did with them why i left the left
has been seen over 20 million times it
at least
is the intro to the right ideas and then
i suppose it's up to better places
of education to take it from there but i
i view
those types of of smaller bites and the
things that we on the youtube
are good at that's sort of the
icebreaker and then we need the
structures that
the three of you guys are talking about
to to really get the ideas home so that
people can get
you know the the right ideas out there
or to learn the right ideas in the first
place
dave this is a very critical point it's
important i think that we not see this
as an either or thing
public school or home school one better
than the other there are so many kids
who for better or for worse are going to
stay in the public school system because
of family situations
financial decisions what have you it's
critical that we on the right figure out
how to
provide families with information that
they can teach their kids
in their home to counteract or
supplement what they're getting in
public school this is actually
this is exactly what we're trying to do
with huddle twins because so many
parents want to be able to provide their
family their kids something better
it's critical i think that we figure out
ways to communicate directly to the
families whatever their education
situation is
all right well corey connor and kerry
you guys should be in a band the three
of you
uh we thank you for joining us and we'll
talk to you soon
thank you thank you thank you
my name is gideon shillanas and i'm the
president of foundation for economic
education
for the past 75 years we've been
committed to defending the ideas of
liberty
looking around the world i think you
would agree that these ideas are more
needed than ever
and young people are excited about our
ideas covid has created many unexpected
challenges
but i have some good news too in the
past year alone
we've reached tens of thousands of
students in the classroom and millions
online
we do that through videos webinars
articles and social media
if you want to find out more please go
to fie.org
okay this is our final freedom fest
emergency
edition emergency session breakout
session
and we are going to be talking about
practical solutions
for a free america that seems like the
right way to end
this two-hour discussion uh we've got a
couple great guests i'm going to start
with the one guy who's been on the
reuben report before
matt kibbee usually when we talk about
freedom we somehow
bring it back to star wars do you want
to give me a star wars reference
right up top honestly i feel like the
pandemic
industrial complex is the new death star
and they're exploiting our fears in
order to concentrate power
and at some point palpatine is going to
bring it down on us and destroy
everything that's beautiful about
america
unless the american people fight back
and i think that
the the the entire government reaction
to the pandemic particularly the
lockdowns and we
watch these videos online of of moms
getting tased at high school football
games
i think that the overstep by the
government on this subject
is potentially the next tea party the
next reawakening
of people wanting their liberties back
and wanting more autonomy over their
personal lives
and realizing that our overlords in the
health industrial complex
in the pandemic industrial complex they
don't know nearly as much
as they claim to kibby i knew you could
give me a star wars reference
and a well thought out philosophical
point i thought you might
say that uh there was a great moment
last night where joe biden
said that i said i am the democratic
party which really had a little bit of
palpatine
i am the senate uh mark can you
introduce our other panelists
i will but i thought didn't joe biden
say i
am darth vader
that's the next step that's the next
step once he becomes president
uh i guess
so our other guests are david friedman
who is a
legal authority and an economist
at santa clara university in california
he is sconced in his library it appears
david we're glad to have you here and we
have also mcgott wade
who is from austin texas and she is with
the atlas network
and is the director of the center for
african prosperity
so uh that's a very optimistic title i
like that a lot
and uh so let's let's uh let me ask a
question to david first
um david you're a legal scholar how can
the government get away with the
bridging our
freedom to peaceful assemble
to freedom of religion freedom of speech
it seems like all of these
have been a bridge with these executive
orders what authority do they have to
legitimately do this
if you mean legally i suppose the
ultimate answer is the fact that most of
the courts will back them
uh we've had at least one case so far of
a judge who
i think in pennsylvania found that there
was no such authority
and that would depend in detail on the
state constitution i think since it's
almost all of it has been done at the
state level not at the
not at the federal level
beyond that uh as far as i can tell
there are sort of very wide and rather
vague authorities
under the usual legal rules about
epidemics and contagion and so forth we
know that isolating a typhoid mary was
considered legal and
i think arguably should have been and
then it's very hard you know there
aren't a lot of bright lines in the
world unfortunately
and it's if if you imagine for a moment
that this disease were about
20 times as bad as it is you then
probably would also be in favor of
saying people aren't allowed to get
together and spread the disease and
i think as it as it's turned out it's
pretty clear that the reaction was a
considerable overreaction
but i don't think we i don't think we
live in a in a world
in which you can take a constitutional
provision as a really sharp bright line
that
that uh you know we we're supposed to
have the government not be involved in
religion
but that really isn't possible that the
government makes decisions
those decisions are affected by your
religious beliefs if you
believe if you really believed that
certain activities would result in god
raining
fire and brimstone down on the city you
would think it was appropriate to forbid
those
those activities but of course if you
don't
believing that a religion is false is
also a religious belief
so i think if you really look at it uh
the rules that we would like to think of
is really sharp bright line rules rarely
are
and when things look terrible when
there's a war on or a disease
people tend to push uh pretty far
uh on on those fuzzy lines
david let me follow up with another
question should there be any limits to
executive power
during an emergency some states for
example
say after 30 days the executive order to
continue
uh has to receive the approval of the
legislature i believe that's the case in
in utah in hawaii
not in nevada but so it depends on the
state but
aren't you shocked by how much power
these people have
wielded and should what kind of limits
can we place upon these emergency powers
even during a quarantine and actually i
am not shocked
that if you think about things that
happen say during world war ii
when a whole lot of japanese americans
were locked up when there was no
evidence they committed any crime at all
and
and actually the arguments for doing it
turn out to have been largely bogus
so when people get scared things happen
you know that's
i think you have to have to allow for
that in the real world unfortunately
uh now i think i think it is it makes
sense to say
that executive authority only overrides
the ordinary rules for a very short term
because the legislature can then meet
but i don't think it's not clear to me
the legislature would have made just
different decisions in most states
the i guess the last couple of
presidents i think have been
particularly aggressive about the idea
that they want to do things and there
doesn't have to be congress willing to
go along so they'll do them anyway and
so far congress has been mostly
unwilling to call them on it
yeah you know if you think of most of
most of the overreaction by the
executive at the federal level
really is a case of congress not
stopping it that that you know the
congress
the the the constitution is quite clear
that the president can't declare war
and yet we've what i think
treasurer what was the last time that we
actually had a real declaration of war
maybe korea
i'm not sure no no world war not even
korea
so so basically congress has taken the
position well we're not declaring war
we're just dropping bombs on people and
and the president is allowed he's the
head of the military after all he's
allowed to drop bombs on people
so no i don't i
anyway i think i think what you what you
really want to ask
is not what should happen but what's
your best prediction of what will happen
that in general i think one of the
mistakes with a lot of political
argument
is that people argue about the ends that
they claim
to achieve rather than about the means
that that somebody says we want a
government that will help the poor
and they don't ask given the nature of
government will it in fact help the poor
or will it buy the votes of the poor
with money from people who aren't poor
the votes of the
middle class with money from the poor
and the rich the votes of the rich with
money from the poor in the middle class
and sort of transfer in all directions
so anyway that would be another long
story but
but i think i think i am less optimistic
perhaps than you are about the ability
of a
legal rule like a constitution to
actually restrict governments that
that as you know i'd like to
if i can switch now to uh my god
and talk to you about freedom
and race i think is a really important
issue
do we we have all kinds of laws on the
books now
that prohibit discrimination
uh are those uh are
have those laws worked or are we
entering a society in the united states
let alone africa or anywhere else
where racism is is getting worse
or do you think it's getting better and
to what extent do we have
a free society in terms of
uh pursuit of happiness
pursuit of work pursuit to live your own
life the way you
way you wish uh and and do it
for all americans
oh you're let's see i think you might be
muted
there we go yes to answer your first
question
uh mark i will go ahead and say the way
i feel it
um it's as black women
i believe that there is no better time
than uh to be alive then to 2020.
simple if anyone wants to go back to any
point in life um
you know from that step from the racism
standpoint
bring it on i i think this is the best
time for any black person to be alive
uh from from that standpoint now if you
want to talk about
um pre-slavery africa that's a whole
other thing but even then i would not
want to have been a live vent
because of you know we didn't have all
the things we have
today so in any case uh from from a
material standpoint that's what i mean
so um so that's what i want to put out
first and then when it comes to
um race racism
freedom where do we go for what's what's
what's ahead
i am actually very very optimistic about
the future i feel that um this crisis
uh brought in by covid and the lockdowns
um and then even with um
the the disastrous and
the death of george that's what i'm
talking about here the death of george
floyd
the aftermath of all of that and black
lives matter coming um
to the front you know i
passionately believe in the ideas of
black lives
in the three words black lives matter
verse three words together
passionately passionately as a black
person believe in what those words mean
but i absolutely have no selfie with the
organization
itself and what they stand for anywhere
from
their rejection of you know this idea
that a child
needs a family you know to to bet to do
better in life
and also quite frankly i'm quite put off
by their marxist ideas
and the anti-capitalist ideas so
what i the reason why i think there is
something interesting here that's been
happening
though is for the longest time a lot of
black people in america have just been
like
yeah black lives matter black lives
matter of course of course they don't
dissociate
the organization of the organization
with
what these three words mean but today
now that it has been
it has come so so much to the front
everybody started looking more and do
you know how many of my black friends
i have here in america that tell me you
know i really don't identify with black
lives matter the organization
they're starting to go deeper and
they're starting to see these elements
and i am also starting to see friends
standing up
stronger and more for no it is important
for a child to be
to be born in a two-parent um household
so i'm seeing a lot of conversations
that are happening now
and a lot of questionings that are
happening now that i did not see happen
before
and i think those are great questioning
so i'm very
um optimistic from that standpoint and
another thing has to do with
when you look at the equation of the
success equation you know finish high
school first
yet we know that 60 of black male will
not finish high school
then um make sure that you get a job uh
full-time job
next and then if you're gonna have
children try to bring them in a two
people's household
uh if you shouldn't have children well
what i'm seeing is
um that even there
sorry um when you look at the education
on the education side finish high school
well a lot of black people now
are finding some type of liberation with
the fact that you know
school doesn't happen directly you
people cannot
they close the schools so now folks have
to go over
and teach your children from from from
home it is hard for many people for
different reasons and this is a debate
for another day
but what i am seeing here is that um a
lot of black parents
are actually um making finally a a
distinction
a lot of them are starting to look at
what is that their kids were learning or
not learning
so there too i do think that the free
choice movement is
um has amazing really great days ahead
of itself so talking about freedom
with uh you know school choice is is
really going to be
big going forward so i'm very excited
about that and especially as to what it
means
for this very bad um you know percentage
that we have of black people supposedly
who are not going to finish high school
so i believe that with
um school choice more of these black
boys are going to get to finish high
school which
is going to work for them in the long
term and last but not least
uh conversations that i have also seen
happen because of this
violence and the rights and everything
is actually now people being willing to
put on the table
this conversation that needs to happen
which is what i call black culture
matters
okay if you want to have
um to thrive in a society culture really
does matter
culture does matter and there are
universal traits of character
that will allow you to do well no matter
who you are no matter what skin color
you are no matter what gender you are no
matter
who you are so those compositions are
now coming to the table
and as i'm speaking to you i have a show
called
um we call it uh catcher drip so catch
food drip is basically a show where we
invite in the rappers
the hip hop artists the people who have
given the black culture black urban
culture a very very bad name so far
and we're giving them a chance for
redemption where we actually get to talk
about the very strong traits of
characters that everybody should have
if you're gonna make it from point a to
point b and the last one is going to be
a podcast called
black culture matters where we go deep
on these issues
anyone else would bring up these issues
they would be called racist
anything we bring it on and we're going
to talk about the need
for we need to kill the senseless
violence that's happening in the black
urban
communities and someone has to talk
about it and we're going there and this
conversation has never been a better
time to have them than now so
from so many many many many standpoints
life threw lemons at us with kovid and
everything that has ensued
but i guarantee you that many black
people are working behind the scene
right now and we're going to make the
best lemonade out of this so
i'm very very optimistic
all right a little optimism that was
that was by far the most optimism that
we've gotten in these two hours so i
like seeing that silver lining
i want to stick with the with the race
thing for just a minute because you gave
a couple interesting offshoots there
that we could jump to
uh matt i'll throw this one to you uh
but it seems to me that a lot of people
seem to
think that the government is supposed to
solve
racism uh when in many cases
um we've actually gotten racism out of
the equation already but even if you
watched the debate last night you know
biden actually called trump racist and
they got into that stuff about critical
race theory in 1619 project and
everything else
but what underlies that is somehow that
the government is supposed to be the
entity
that will deal with this sort of
innately human problem is that just like
the complete wrong framing of this
well it's it's laughable because if you
look at the murder of george floyd and i
would add the decision that just came
down about briona taylor
these are teachable moments about all
the things that government abuse of
power has wrought on the black community
uh starting with the drug war but but
starting with i i think there is a
disparate outcome
when it comes to to the enforcement of
laws and a lot of it has to do with the
drug war
which itself has very racist roots
so i think i think it's a teachable
moment
where a lot of people that are looking
for government to solve
problems like racism guess what guys
they created the problem in the first
place
and by the way they love pitting us
against each other they love
dividing us they love using it as a
wedge issue to win the next election
and i think again just like the mom
getting
tased at her son's football game sort of
woke up to conservatives about about
what happens when government goes too
far
i think briona taylor is a is a
cautionary
lesson about what happens when you give
government too much power they abuse it
they always abuse it
and the only way to take it back is
through peaceful
grassroots mobilization the violence
actually helps the bad guys
so i see we have just added uh uh
stephen hicks
has a has joined us uh thank you for
coming
and uh stephen is with the senior fellow
with the
atlas society uh for professor hicks
uh since you're in the education field
and
writing and so forth uh uh we were
talking about racism
uh the narrative now
is to teach in all the schools that
racism is
inherent that you can't get away from it
that it it's never going away
what's been your experience with
minority students that you teach uh
are we able to have a consensus as all
americans or are we now divided
yeah well i'm going to sign on with uh
magat i'm
actually a short-term pessimist i think
we have a generational problem
but i'm a medium-term optimist because i
think we will get past this cultural
moment
uh and there are a lot of signs that
we're going to do i do think
we do have a racism problem i think it's
overblown
and oversold and the roots of it are not
primarily political but i think they are
cultural
and cognitive what we have
unfortunately is a whole generation of
people who are under schooled
undereducated and racism
is a defense mechanism for those who uh
who adopt it against what they see as a
world that is too difficult and too
complicated for them to understand
if you're smart if you know your stuff
if you can rely on your own
individual judgment to take on the world
to make your business and family life
and so forth a go
then you will be oriented toward
independence and self-responsibility
but if you are by the time you approach
adulthood
uh uh in your honest self-assessment
aware
that the world is difficult that you
don't have good math skills you don't
have good
social cultural skills you don't
understand the way the world works we're
living in this very
complicated scientific and technological
society
it is overwhelming and i do see
not just minority students but it's it's
broader than that
uh an increasing number of freshman
students who come in and they
are not cognitively able to to handle
the world so the point then is going to
be psychologically if
you don't think you can take on the
world independently and make a go of it
and this is the distressing thing for
those of us who are fierce in our love
of liberty and self-responsibility
to realize how many people then are
looking for
someone to look after them in some sense
and it doesn't necessarily mean
an overtly authoritarian big daddy
either in the sky or
in government but they are looking for
social networks that they can join in
that they think will look after them so
family is a kind of social unit and
people will give up a lot of freedom and
autonomy
to belong to the family if they have
this psychological sense that it's going
to look after them
ethnic groups and racial groups are
another uh
easy source for people to latch on to so
i don't think that people are innately
racist i don't think that uh
i i don't know governments do some
disincentivizing things for people in
the wrong direction
we do have over ideological racists
who've been doing a certain a lot of
indoctrination but in my judgment
the main issue is a cognitive
deficiency that leads people to seek
safety
in a group and racial groups are a
prominent group in which they can get a
sense of identity
stephen i have to say you're you're
echoing my
my old friend jordan peterson a message
that he talked about a lot which was
clean your room first and we have too
many people that think they have to
clean the world first and deal with all
the world's issues first but if they
could actually
just deal with some of their own issues
first that then you can
you can build the world forward where
these days we seem to think that
everything should come
top down when in effect it should be
bottom up
yeah no uh orthogonal to the
the point i'm making but directly
directly complementary
if you uh have a certain sense of vacuum
in your own life and another way you can
try to think
i'm going to find some meaning in my
life instead of putting together a
meaningful life for myself is just put
everything out onto the world i become a
world
savior and uh that gives me a sense of a
scheme
so i'd like to ask i'm a i'm a sports
fan
and i don't give you love sports
uh i'm a big nba basketball fan
in college sports and so forth well now
uh every nba game has a big uh
banner right on the floor that says
black lives matter
am i going to have to suffer through
every time i watch a sporting event is
it going to be
political from now on or can i just sit
and enjoy
the game uh do you want uh any one of us
in particular to take that up
you're asking if we have any sports fans
i can't stand to watch the nba games
anymore
not that i have any problem with race
issues and stuff like that it's just
that
sports entertainment there's a lot of
areas if i go to a concert
to hear a rock and roll band just keep
your politics to yourself
i just want to hear uh uh
the boss saying uh or paul mccartney i
don't have to
i don't want to hear political
commentary is that mark you may
mark you may note that i have a i have a
nba basketball it was actually used in a
practice right above me
on the i don't know if it's fully in the
frame here but i did not watch one
minute of i have not watched one minute
of the nba this season
uh because i don't like the messaging
but i think the question is actually
let's throw it to magat because you made
the point the difference between black
lives matter
the the idea that all black lives people
all black people's lives matter which of
course
any rational person agrees with versus
the the organization black lives matter
and it seems that the nba
is in effect endorsing the organization
when they put
their messaging on the court it
seems to me that there are several
things happening
let's go to my guy sorry yes
no um i think they're making a big
mistake i i think
um again i will i passionately
uh stand behind the meaning of a free
word black lives matter
of course that being said um
be if you put your weight behind the
organization i think it's a terrible
mistake
that they're making time will
time will correct that mistake because
this is where actually
i love the power of a free market to
to solve and correct the situation and
it will correct itself
so i'm not too worried about that but
what i wanted to say real quick is to go
back to
something that um stephen you were
saying earlier
uh and um dave you were talking about
jordan peterson in
his you know clean your own room first i
think that maybe the reason why for
jordan peterson it has
resonated with so many people and they i
think actually
his audience maybe has more white people
than not i don't know don't quote me on
that
but i can tell you that uh based on my
uh work now with
african americans in this country i
discovered something that has been
missing with the message clean your own
room first and this message of
pull up pull yourself up by the
bootstraps where we lose
um folks in terms of uh for this message
of self-agency
is because i really really so many of us
have no
beginning of an understanding of
the threshold at which some folks are
starting
you know when i interview some rappers
and they tell you that
they were born and this woman it could
have been me
when she told you that she was born to
two parents and their claim to fame in
the neighborhood
was that they were the best drug dealers
in the neighborhood and they started
selling drugs so that they could
make it economically speaking because
that may be the only opportunity so we
can sit here and judge those parents
all we want any day anytime but now i'm
looking at that little girl her name is
free unity
and she's now grown of course her dad
committed suicide when she was five her
mom started using the derby at seven
i think that not enough of us put
ourselves in the shoes of someone like
that
when we try to say no matter what
happened to you
you're responsible for what you do for
you and then i would like for us to add
and we will help you with it starting
where you are so i think that our
message whether it's
thomas glenn larry all of these folks
that i absolutely adore and respect
on our side of the spectrum who say all
the things that they say
it just comes across too much as you
should you must you ought you have
and blah blah blah yes we know the data
we know everything but can we
also start mixing to that what someone
like bishop omar
based in dallas is doing with the ogu
movement his odu movement where we're
saying okay
we understand exactly where you're
coming from and we know where we should
you should go
we're going to walk with you so you come
from this environment we're going to
bring
with with us people who know your
background and we're going to take you
to the other side from there so i do
think that our side
with this whole self-agency message it's
a wonderful message but the reason why
it's falling flat
on the ears of those who should pay
attention to this is because
we kind of missed the last mile of
bridging to them and i think that mile
is crucial it's critical but if we take
it if we take it
we win we win because black people will
finally achieve prosperity and with that
prosperity they're going to get the
respect that they deserve
and from there watch all of this poof
poof poof poof
and poof so that's what i'm saying my
god this is me officially inviting you
to come on my show to talk about just
that so that we can get these ideas out
there how about that
i know david had a comment and follow up
david
do do laws against discrimination
have any unintended consequences
obviously they do uh if you know that
it's hard to fire blacks
you're going to be reluctant to hire
them that would be the most obvious
example
but i think more generally that one of
the reasons for racial problems
is the shift of more and more activities
into the political sphere
that the market is usually a situation
where individuals interests are
compatible where if
you are good at doing something and i
need somebody who's good at doing that i
want to hire you to do it you want to be
hired to do it
in the political system you're much more
nearly playing in a zero-sum game
where what i want to do is to make up a
coalition of people like me
in order to make sure that we get more
of the pie which means you get less of
the pie
so i think in that sense making the
world more political
has a negative effect in terms of
racial and other kinds of group
conflicts because it creates a world
where you want is a coalition that will
result in your winning
whereas the market most of the time uh
is not in that situation
but the other thing that struck me about
the the earlier comment about the black
lives matter thing in the
basketball court is that a bunch of
different things are happening at once
which is usually the case in the world
one of them is a fundamentalist religion
which you can think of roughly as wokism
which like a lot of other fundamentalist
religions results in some people being
very very enthusiastic
and being willing to push very hard for
what they think is
holy and right and so forth and people
who
both don't want to fight them and have
no very strong views on the subject
are naturally inclined to go along so i
think if you look at
at say the status of christianity and
much of u.s history
there were an awful lot of people who
for public purposes
were christians and said christian
things didn't actually believe in it
but there were enough people who did
believe in it so it was sensible to
pretend to be that i mean
i was struck by this whole a lot quite a
while back there was talk about whether
obama was a muslim
and it was clear he wasn't a muslim
because muslims have to pray a certain
number of times a day and it would have
been pretty obvious
my question is is he a christian i know
he said he's a christian
it could be he's a christian but given
the political environment
it paid it was in the interest of almost
any politician
to claim to agree with the majority
religion because he didn't want to lose
voters
i don't know whether any high
yeah i would say if the of the last
bunch of presidents
probably a majority of them i have no
way of knowing if they actually believed
in the religion they claimed to believe
in
so i think it's worth it's worth
thinking about the world in those terms
and how people act and i suspect that at
the moment
if you don't go along with the more or
less woke
sort of shibboleth as it were
it's costly to you you'll get people
protesting against you and such
if you do it doesn't cost you anything
my guess is that
like other fundamentalist religions the
furor will die down but unfortunately it
may take a while because these things
you know if you think about islam i
would say it lasted for 50 or 100 years
during which people were really
enthusiastic about it and then started
sliding downhill with occasional
revivals at various points and i think
that's
been true historically of christianity
as well that the number of people who
really believe in
in any religion is not nearly as high as
it appears to be
but the number of people who sort of
will i guess i suppose i believe in it
and i think that's going to be true of
locism as as well and
to what extent pushing too hard is going
to cause a reaction i'm not quite sure
because you've certainly had a
noticeable amount of people objecting to
various uh things happening associated
with
sort of generally progressive ideologies
seen as a religion
but anyway perhaps by divine
intervention we ran out of time just as
we
introduced religion into the equation i
don't know how that worked
but but here we are thank you guys for
joining us
on on this panel and i i think people
will will hopefully feel
a little more hopeful thank you
all right a pleasure thanks everyone
all right so that is our freedom fest
emergency
session mark i've thoroughly enjoyed
co-hosting this with you i have a
feeling that my audience
uh absolutely enjoyed it you know so
much of what we talked about these are
these are the core issues
that i've been talking about on this
show for the last couple years
and you know for the for the minor
points of disagreement that we heard
throughout this because they really were
only minor
the broader point is that every single
person that we talked to over the last
couple hours
wants us to live in a more free society
and if we can just keep pushing those
ideas
as you guys do with freedom fest then i
think we'll have done our part
in this crazy world that we live in uh
davey you're so right
and it has been a real pleasure working
with you for the first time
and uh we are common mind in our goal
for
a free society an open society right now
we're living in a very dangerous time
period because
everything is is closing up i mean it's
hard to travel
it's hard to meet with people it's hard
to go to school on a normal basis
the political situation is divisive
and disagreeable to say the least
there are a lot of problems that we face
one of the reasons i started freedom
fast back in
2007 this is going to be our 14th year
coming up
um is because i sense that we had
we had lost something in our society and
we needed to get it back
and so i hope all of you will join with
us
for next year's freedom fest event uh
it's going to be a really fun time
uh and we're going to definitely meet
in person that is our goal we're not
going to let this happen to us again
where we're shut down by the imperial
authorities
uh if you would like to support us more
there is a donate button
at the at the bottom here of our
announcement uh of our uh emergency
session and i hope you'll take the
opportunity to uh donate to
uh a good cause and uh i thank you all
for participating in our emergency
meeting
and if you like what we're doing we'll
probably do it again
but our key is to gather together
as a free people that is our
our goal and we know as a result of that
good things will come about it we've had
many letters from people
saying that freedom fest was the best
conference they've ever attended so
i hope you'll be part of it uh and we
look forward to
giving you some updates from time to
time about
our program next year healthy wealthy
and wise
is our theme and i think it's it's an
important one
that you all want to be a part of john
mackey the ceo of whole foods market and
steve forbes our co-ambassadors
they will both be there as long as some
real headliners
along with dave rubin and others it's
really going to be an exciting time
so until then thank you all and may you
live
free and happy and safe lives thank you